This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. When things go wrong in our relationships, we often try to change the way our partners behave. We tell ourselves that if only they would change their ways, we could be happy. Of course, the problem is, our partners are saying the same thing about us. Last week, we explored the power of a radically different approach. acceptance. Instead of trying to change our partners, Clark University psychologist James Cordova says there's growing evidence that we will end up in much happier relationships
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。当我们在关系中遇到问题时，我们常常试图改变伴侣的行为方式。我们对自己说，只要他们改变方式，我们就能幸福。当然，问题在于，我们的伴侣也在对我们说同样的话。上周，我们探讨了一种截然不同的方法的力量：接纳。克拉克大学的心理学家詹姆斯·科尔多瓦表示，越来越多的证据表明，如果我们能接受伴侣本来的样子，我们将最终拥有更幸福的关系
if we can accept our partners for who they are. If you miss that story, you can find it in this podcast feed. It's titled How to Fix Your Marriage Part 1. Today, we look at one of the most toxic things we do in intimate relationships. Changing this behavior is not easy, and the ideas we explore today can be a tough pill to swallow. If the thing that we most want in our relationship is to feel that sense of love and connection and acceptance for each other, this is my relationship. I have to take responsibility for what happens in every moment, and everything that I do and say matters. How to become wiser in our relationships.
而不是试图改变他们。如果你错过了那个故事，你可以在这个播客动态中找到它。它的标题是《如何修复你的婚姻 第一部分》。今天，我们将探讨亲密关系中最具破坏性的行为之一。改变这种行为并不容易，我们今天探讨的观点可能很难让人接受。如果我们在这段关系中最渴望的是感受到彼此的爱、连接和接纳，这就是我的关系。我必须为每一时刻发生的事情承担责任，我所做和所说的一切都很重要。如何让我们的关系变得更加明智。
It's the latest in our Love 2.0 series this week on Hidden Brain. So much of our distress and relationships comes about, not only because we want to change another person but find ourselves unable to do so, but because we sense that the other person could change if they wanted to and just isn't trying hard enough. If I feel you can fix a problem but can't be bothered to do it, surely I'm justified in blaming you. Psychologist James Cordova has spent many years studying this particular cycle in relationships.
这是本周《隐藏的大脑》“爱2.0”系列节目的最新内容。我们在关系中经历的许多痛苦，不仅是因为我们想改变另一个人却发现自己无能为力，还因为我们觉得只要对方愿意，他们本可以改变，只是不够努力。如果我觉得你可以解决问题却懒得去做，那我责怪你就绝对是情有可原的。心理学家詹姆斯·科尔多瓦花了很多年研究关系中的这种特殊循环。
James, can you talk about the role that blame plays as we try and change another person? This is a fundamental psychological characteristic for all of us. Whenever we experience distress with other people, we let ourselves off the hook that can't possibly be my fault. Everything that I do is completely understandable and justifiable. So therefore, it has to be your fault. And we're raised in a culture. we come out of a place where we imagine that the way to solve a problem starts with figuring out who's to blame. And then once we figure out who's to blame, then we know how to solve the
詹姆斯，你能谈谈在我们试图改变另一个人时，责怪扮演了什么角色吗？这是我们所有人身上一个基本的心理特征。每当我们在与他人的交往中感到痛苦时，我们就会为自己开脱，心想这绝对不可能是我的错。我所做的一切都是完全可以理解且合情合理的。所以因此，这一定是你的错。我们在一种文化中长大，我们从这样一个地方走出来：我们想象解决问题的方法始于弄清楚是谁的错。一旦我们弄清楚是谁的错，我们就知道如何解决
problem. And in relationships, that almost never helps, it almost always follows the pattern of you're to blame. No, I'm not. You're to blame. No, I'm not. No, I'm not. No, I'm not. No, I'm not. And we can spend years in that spot in our relationship, trying to convince the other person that I'm not to blame you are. I would say in the history of history, that approach to trying to solve problems in our intimate relationships has never actually worked. You know, what you just said, James,
这个问题了。但在关系中，这几乎永远没有帮助，它几乎总是遵循这样的模式：是你的错。不，不是我。是你的错。不，不是我。不，不是我。不，不是我。不，不是我。我们可以在关系的那个地方度过数年，试图说服对方不是我的错，是你的错。我想说，在历史的历史长河中，这种试图解决我们亲密关系中问题的方法其实从未真正奏效过。你知道，詹姆斯，你刚才说的话
reminds me of a conversation I had with another hidden brain guest some time ago. You know, he said that when we were in high school, we often would go into debate championships or debate tournaments where you would try and make your case and then somebody else would make their case, and then a judge would decide who had the better argument and would award one person, the trophy of the winner. And he was pointing out that we often approach our relationships in regular life the same way that we approach, you know, debate championships. We assume that if we make our argument persuasively enough, that a neutral party, a judge, is going to somehow come and hand us the award, the trophy,
让我想起了一段时间前我和另一位《隐藏的大脑》嘉宾的对话。你知道，他说过，当我们在高中时，我们经常参加辩论锦标赛或辩论赛，在那里你会试图陈述你的理由，然后其他人陈述他们的理由，接着裁判会决定谁的论点更好，并把胜利者的奖杯颁发给其中一个人。他指出，我们在现实生活中对待关系的方式，往往和我们对待辩论锦标赛的方式一样。我们假设，如果我们足够有说服力地陈述我们的论点，一个中立的第三方、一个裁判就会以某种方式出现，把奖项、奖杯交给我们
and say, you are right, the other person is wrong, you've won, the debate is over. But of course, in real life, there is no judge. It's just two people who are both debating one another with no one to actually settle the debate. That's so true. And oftentimes, when they come to therapy, they want me to be the judge. And they're very disappointed when I won't do it. Yeah, no, absolutely. Like tell us which one of us is right. And of course it's me, right? And the way that I think about that is, and the way that I talk to couples about that is it's like two fire hoses pointed at each other. Everybody's trying so hard to win. Everybody's trying so hard to be understood and to have their argument accepted. And nobody's listening.
并说，你是对的，另一个人是错的，你赢了，辩论结束了。但当然，在现实生活中，没有裁判。只有两个人互相辩论，却没有人来真正平息这场辩论。确实如此。而且通常情况下，当他们来做心理治疗时，他们希望我当裁判。而当我拒绝这样做时，他们会非常失望。是的，不，绝对是这样。就像告诉我们我们俩谁是对的。当然是我，对吧？我对这件事的看法，以及我与伴侣们探讨的方式是，这就像两个水龙头互相喷水。每个人都在拼命想要赢。每个人都在拼命想要被理解，想要让自己的论点被接受。而没有人真正在听。
And we can do that, again, for years. We can exhaust ourselves. You're just not understanding me. No, you're just not understanding me. James once had to help a couple who were caught in this trap. The main area where they would have so much conflict would be in any project that they were working on around the house and um he would often want to do things in the ways that he considered to be the right way very meticulous cross all the t's dot all the eyes
而且我们可以这样做，再次强调，可以持续多年。我们可以让自己精疲力竭。你就是不理解我。不，你就是不理解我。詹姆斯曾不得不帮助一对陷入这个陷阱的夫妻。他们产生最多冲突的领域是他们围绕房子进行的任何项目，嗯，他经常想以他认为正确的方式做事，非常一丝不苟，字斟句酌，把每个细节都处理好
and she would feel like you're making it way too complicated and you're just dragging this thing out and so she would try to steamroll him and he would be the immovable object so she's the unstoppable force and he's the immovable object. And neither one of them ever felt any satisfaction coming out of that sense of it's your fault that we're fighting about this because you're trying to get everything perfect. No, it's your fault that we're fighting about this because you're just trying to do it the cheap and easy way. I mean, every movie that I've seen that involves a couple arguing or fighting with each other, has some version of the dynamic you just described, James? Absolutely. And for a reason, because it is so common. You know,
而她会觉得你把它搞得太复杂了，你只是在拖延时间，所以她会试图强行推进，而他则是不动摇的对象，所以她是势不可挡的力量，而他是不动摇的对象。他们两个人在这种“我们为此争吵是你的错，因为你想把一切做到完美；不，我们为此争吵是你的错，因为你只想用便宜又简单的方式去做”的感觉中，从来没有感受到过任何满足感。我的意思是，我看过的每一部涉及伴侣争吵或打架的电影，都有你刚刚描述的这种动态的一些版本，詹姆斯？绝对是的。而且是有原因的，因为它太常见了。你知道，
our, it is our natural instincts to think the reason that we're fighting is because you're being pickheaded. I'm wondering as our listeners are listening to this, conversation, I'm sure that the thought that's going through the minds of many people is, James Cordova might be right about other couples and other relationships, but in my case, it really is my partner who is to blame. How do we tell the difference between a partner who might genuinely be to blame and what is just garden variety self-delusion, James? That's such a good question. You know, what I am often asking couples to do is to enter
我们的，我们的本能是认为我们争吵的原因是因为你太固执了。我在想，当我们的听众在听这段对话时，我确信许多人脑海中闪过的想法是：詹姆斯·科尔多瓦对其他伴侣和其他关系可能是对的，但在我的情况下，真正该责怪的确实是我的伴侣。詹姆斯，我们该如何区分一个真正该受到责怪的伴侣和那些只是普通的自我欺骗呢？这是一个非常好的问题。你知道，我经常要求伴侣们做的是接受
the radical notion that maybe I play at least a small part in this. And if we take that and expand it, we can expand it into what if something that I'm doing is actually an essential part of what's keeping us stuck here. And so we can discover how to properly assign blame. if we first do a thorough sort of assessment of, in what way might I actually be contributing to this? And from that place, like, if what I'm contributing to this is my judgment of my partner's behavior that's actually making it harder for them to change, then if I can shift that to understanding why they're doing what they're doing,
这样一个激进的观念：也许我在其中至少扮演了一小部分角色。如果我们接受这一点并将其扩展，我们可以把它扩展到：如果我正在做的某件事实际上是让我们陷入僵局的关键部分呢？因此，如果我们首先对“我到底在以什么方式促成了这一切”进行彻底的评估，我们就能发现如何正确地归咎。从这个角度来看，如果我对此的贡献是对伴侣行为的批判，这实际上让他们更难改变，那么如果我能将这种批判转变为理解他们为什么要这样做
empathizing with why it feels so important to them, it actually allows them to come out of that defensive stance and to begin to entertain the possibility that maybe I could see this in a more complicated way. Maybe I'm not super happy with my behavior either, but I'm never going to admit that if all I'm getting from you is judgment. If I'm getting understanding from you, then I can start to entertain my own ambivalence about things that maybe are not particularly healthy.
对他们为什么觉得这如此重要产生共鸣，这实际上能让他们卸下防备，开始考虑这样一种可能性：也许我可以从一个更复杂的角度来看待这个问题。也许我对自己的行为也不是非常满意，但如果我从你这里得到的只有评判，我永远不会承认这一点。如果我从你这里得到的是理解，那么我就可以开始正视自己内心对于那些可能并不特别健康的事务的矛盾心理。
James acknowledges there is a paradox here. The less we try to change our partners, the more our partners become willing to change. It is the paradox of acceptance. I think the way that it works is that when we are trying so hard in all the ways that we know how to change others, to change ourselves and just being stuck in that spot, our world becomes very narrow. Our repertoire becomes very narrow. It's as though we've fallen into the delusion that the only way through. this wall is to beat my head against it. And it's not until we can take that deep breath and take that step back and develop a more intimate relationship with our own wanting, with our
詹姆斯承认这里存在一个悖论。我们越是不去试图改变伴侣，我们的伴侣就越是愿意改变。这就是接纳的悖论。我认为它的运作方式是这样的：当我们用尽所知的所有方法去拼命改变他人、改变自己，却仅仅陷入那种状态时，我们的世界就会变得非常狭隘。我们的应对手段也会变得非常狭隘。这就好像我们陷入了一种错觉，以为穿过这堵墙的唯一方法就是用头去撞它。直到我们能够深吸一口气，退后一步，对我们自己的渴望建立更亲密的联系——对我们的
own desperation, our own yearning for change, without trying to get that change, that things start to open up and in a place where there was no opportunity. for creative problem solving. We start to be able to see it from a bigger perspective and we can find creative ways forward that we couldn't otherwise see. The paradox is that if we're accepting so that we can get change,
自己的绝望、对改变的渴望，而不去强求这种改变时，事情才开始出现转机；而在一个原本没有创造性解决问题机会的地方，我们开始能够从一个更大的视角来看待它，并找到以前无法看到的创造性前进道路。这个悖论在于，如果我们是为了获得改变而进行接纳，
like, you know what you're doing. You know what you're up to. You can't trick yourself, right? Like, oh, I'm going to accept this, and then it's going to change. It never works that way. Like, it has to be genuine acceptance. It has to be a kind of surrender.
就像，你知道自己在做什么。你知道你在搞什么名堂。你无法欺骗自己，对吧？比如，哦，我要接受这个，然后它就会改变。从来都不是这样的。这必须是真诚的接纳。这必须是一种投降。
And when that surrender is thorough, then things change. But you can't cheat the system. When we come back, one of the most difficult lessons in acceptance. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist James Cordova studies the science of acceptance. He has found that when couples are in conflict with each other, one of the most common things they do is to blame one another for the problems they are experiencing.
当这种投降是彻底的时候，事情就会改变。但你无法欺骗这个系统。当我们回来时，将探讨接纳中最困难的课程之一。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。心理学家詹姆斯·科尔多瓦研究接纳的科学。他发现，当伴侣彼此发生冲突时，最常见的做法之一就是将他们所经历的问题归咎于对方。
If only my partner would do something different, we tell ourselves, both of us could be happy. The blame game rarely results in happy relationships. Some time ago, James came up with a different formulation. Instead of trying to blame your partner, what happens if you eat the blame yourself? Eat the blame is a phrase that comes out of a story out of Zen Buddhism. And the story goes like this.
我们告诉自己，只要伴侣做点改变，我们俩就能幸福。这种责怪游戏很少能带来幸福的关系。不久前，詹姆斯提出了一种不同的说法。与其试图责怪你的伴侣，如果你把责怪吃下去会怎么样？“吃下责怪”这个短语源自禅宗佛教的一个故事。故事是这样的。
The head cook of the monastery was in a hurry to make the afternoon meal because the morning program had gone long. So he's rushing out into the garden to pull vegetables and to cut grasses. And he accidentally cuts off the head of a snake and includes it in the soup for the afternoon meal. So traditionally, Zen Buddhists are vegetarian. So having a little bit of snakehead in the meal is a no-no. But all of the monks are exclaiming about how delicious the soup is today. And there's a point during the meal when the teacher, the head of the monastery, holds a snake head up in his chopsticks and says, what is this? and the head chef sees that and jumps up from his spot, runs over, grabs the snake head in his own
寺庙的主厨急着做午餐，因为早上的活动拖延了时间。所以他急忙跑到菜园里拔蔬菜、割草。结果他不小心砍断了一条蛇的头，并把它放进了午餐的汤里。按照传统，禅宗佛教徒是素食主义者。所以在饭菜里有一点蛇头是犯忌讳的。但所有的僧人都赞叹今天的汤有多么美味。在用餐过程中，有一个时刻，老师、寺庙的住持用筷子夹起一个蛇头说，这是什么？主厨看到这一幕，从座位上跳了起来，跑过去，用自己的
chopsticks, and just eats it. And the whole Zendo just bursts into laughter, right, including the teacher. And the story is about, hey, sometimes we make mistakes. And when we make mistakes, it doesn't have to be an opportunity for deep shame. We can just meet it. Like, oh, there's a snakehead. I'm just going to eat that. We call that eating the blame. In our relationships, it is a spiritual practice. It is a deeply intimate practice to shift from our natural instinct to avoid the blame, to destroy the blame, to escape any possibility that I might be at all to blame.
筷子一把抓起那个蛇头，直接把它吃掉了。整个禅堂瞬间爆发出笑声，对吧，包括老师在内。这个故事是关于，嘿，有时我们会犯错。当我们犯错时，它不一定是一个感到深深羞耻的机会。我们只需面对它。比如，哦，有个蛇头。我要把它吃掉。我们称之为“吃下责怪”。在我们的关系中，这是一种精神修行。这是一种极其亲密的修行，从我们逃避责怪、消灭责怪、逃避任何我可能有一点责任的可能性的本能，
and instead to eat the blame. Something's happened between my partner and I. We're upset at each other. I really want her to apologize. I know I would feel so much better if my partner apologized. And so I'm giving off all my fussy signals, trying to signal to my partner,
转变为去吃下责怪。我和伴侣之间发生了一些事。我们生彼此的气。我真的很想让她道歉。我知道如果伴侣道歉，我会感觉好得多。所以我发出所有烦躁的信号，试图向伴侣暗示，
you need to come over here and make this better. It is deeply emotionally counterintuitive in that moment to think we're upset with each other. I also did something that hurt her and upset her. And what would be the practice of eating the blame in this moment? What did I do? What can I apologize for? And if I can take a deep breath, let myself feel everything, like, man, I really wish she'd be the first one.
你需要过来把事情弄好。在那一刻，心里面产生“我们正在生彼此的气，我也做了一些伤害她、惹恼她的事情，而此刻吃下责怪的修行会是什么样的？”这种想法，在情感上是极其反直觉的。我做了什么？我可以为什么道歉？如果我能深吸一口气，让自己感受这一切，比如，天哪，我真的很希望她是第一个……
And I know that the most skillful thing for me to do, the most agentic thing for me to do. The thing that's going to make the next 15 minutes of our lives better is if I go to her and say, I'm sorry, I could have done that better. That's eating the blame. This has to be incredibly difficult to do, James, because You're saying that precisely at the point at which people are feeling vulnerable and hurt and upset and feeling like their partner has hurt them, you want them to focus on how their partner has been hurt and is upset? I do.
我知道对我来说最巧妙的做法，对我来说最具主体性的做法，能让我们的生活接下来的15分钟变得更好的做法，就是我走到她面前说：“对不起，我本可以做得更好。”这就是吃下责怪。詹姆斯，这一定难得令人难以置信，因为你是在人们感到脆弱、受伤、心烦意乱，觉得自己的伴侣伤害了他们的时候，准确地说是在这个点上，你想让他们专注于他们的伴侣是如何受到伤害和心烦意乱的？我是这么想的。
I do. It is hard. And I think that's why I often say that intimacy is not for the faint of heart. That if the thing that we most want in our relationship is to feel that sense of love and connection and acceptance for each other, this is my relationship. I have to take responsibility for what happens in every moment. And everything that I do and say matters. If I say I'm sorry, it matters.
我是这么想的。这很难。我想这就是为什么我常说亲密关系不适合胆小的人。如果在我们关系中最想要的是感受到彼此的爱、连接和接纳，这就是我的关系。我必须为每一时刻发生的事情承担责任。我所做和所说的一切都很重要。如果我说对不起，这很重要。
If I don't say I'm sorry, it matters. And so wherever the relationship goes, there is something I can do in every moment to steer it in a more, loving in a more intimate direction. And if I'm failing to do that, that's on me. But that is, as you're saying, that is a hard pill to swallow. That's why I think of it. And I talk to my couples about it as a practice. If it was easy, we'd all do it. But it's like learning how to play the guitar. It's like learning how to write poetry. It's like learning a sport. Like nobody's good at it right away. The first time you pick up a guitar, you sound awful. But if you want beautiful,
如果我不说对不起，这也很重要。因此，无论关系走向何方，我在每个时刻都可以做些事情来引导它朝更充满爱、更亲密的方向发展。如果我没能做到这一点，那是我的责任。但正如你所说，这确实是一个难以下咽的苦果。这就是为什么我这样认为，我与我的伴侣们将其视作一种修行。如果这很容易，我们大家都会去做了。但这就像学习弹吉他。这就像学习写诗。这就像学习一项运动。没有人能立刻擅长它。你第一次拿起吉他时，声音糟透了。但如果你想要美丽、
graceful music in your life, you have to practice. If you want deep sustaining intimacy in your relationship, you have to practice. and spiritual traditions who have said, you know, the same thing for centuries. The prayer of St. Francis of Assisi says almost the same thing, word for word, as what you've been telling me here, James, which is, you know, ask not to be consoled as to console, ask not to be understood as to understand, ask not to be loved as to love. And presumably there's a reason these ideas have stuck around for hundreds and hundreds of years. Yeah, I'm a big fan of the prayer of St. Francis. And And for just that reason, because it strikes me that that is hard won wisdom.
优雅的音乐融入你的生活，你必须练习。如果你想在关系中获得深厚、持久的亲密感，你必须练习。几个世纪以来，那些说过同样事情的精神传统也是如此。圣方济各的祈祷文几乎逐字逐句地表达了你在这里对我说过的话，詹姆斯，那就是：不要寻求被安慰，去安慰人；不要寻求被理解，去理解人；不要寻求被爱，去爱人。这些想法存在了成百上千年的时间，想必是有原因的。是的，我是圣方济各祈祷文的超级粉丝。而且正是因为这个原因，因为我觉得这是来之不易的智慧。
I sort of imagine St. Francis, you know, like sitting down to write that almost not from a place of like beatific insight, but almost like hopeless resignation. You know, like, oh, damn, I've been missing this the whole time, right? Like every time I've tried to make myself understood rather than trying to understand, I've made my life worse. Every time I've tried to seek being consoled rather than to console, I've made my relationships worse. It's sort of like you can see him hitting himself in the forehead. Oh, the other way, the other way. And then, you know, out of this great heart of compassion, you know, this sense of, hey guys, What if we did this instead?
我有点想象圣方济各，你知道的，坐下来写下这些，几乎不是出于一种神圣的顿悟，而更像是一种无望的顺从。你知道，就像，哦，该死，我一直以来都搞错了，对吧？就像每次我试图让自己被理解而不是去理解时，我都把生活弄得更糟糕。每次我试图寻求被安慰而不是去安慰时，我都把关系弄得更糟糕。这有点像你能看到他拍打自己的额头。哦，走另一条路，走另一条路。然后，你知道，出于一颗伟大慈悲的心，这种感觉，嘿，伙计们，
What if we sought to understand rather than to be understood? Give it a shot. And this is what I oftentimes almost find myself begging the couples that I'm seeing to do. Just do it for three minutes and see what happens. The medicine that James is offering can seem very difficult. But he points out, the alternative only looks easy. It feels like blaming your partner will get your partner to change his or her ways. James asks a simple question.
如果我们不这样做，而是这样做呢？如果我们寻求去理解而不是被理解呢？试一试吧。而这正是我经常发现自己几乎在恳求我所见到的伴侣们去做的事情。试着做三分钟，看看会发生什么。詹姆斯提供的良药可能看起来非常困难。但他指出，替代方案只是看起来容易。感觉责怪伴侣会让他们改变方式。詹姆斯问了一个简单的问题。
Has it ever done so? Like, name a single time in your life when you've actually had that satisfaction. That satisfaction is an illusion. It is a mirage in the desert of your relationship, right? Like, I am going to fight my way into getting you to accept the blame And then we're both going to feel so madly in love with each other. I'm going to feel accepted. You're going to feel accepted.
这真的管用过吗？举出你生命中哪怕一次真正获得这种满足感的例子。那种满足感是一种幻觉。它是你关系沙漠中的海市蜃楼，对吧？就像，我要通过抗争来让你承认错误，
We're going to go off and make love. And it's going to be great. I promise you it has never happened. That sense of like, I will be satisfied when you submit to my argument that it's your fault never happens. It's an illusion. In our previous episode, again, it's titled How to Fix Your Marriage Part One, and available on hiddenbrain.org or wherever you listen to podcasts, James told the story of how he once upset his wife
然后我们俩都会疯狂地坠入爱河。我会感到被接纳。你会感到被接纳。我们要去卿卿我我。一切都会好起来的。我向你保证，这从未发生过。那种“当你向我的论点屈服，承认是你的错时，我就会感到满足”的感觉从未发生过。这是一种幻觉。在我们的上一集中，同样，标题是《如何修复你的婚姻 第一部分》，可以在 hiddenbrain.org 或你听播客的任何地方找到，詹姆斯讲述了他曾经如何让他的妻子心烦意乱的故事
by making fun of her propensity to always pick the most expensive item when she visited a store. One time, at a shop selling boots in New Mexico, James went up to the salesperson and, in front of his wife, asked him to save everyone a lot of time and simply show her the most expensive pair of shoes in the store. She got very silent, which is what happens when she gets upset. At that moment, you know, after I'd done the thing that I usually do, which is like, let's pretend that didn't happen and had that not work,
因为他取笑了她逛商店时总是挑选最贵商品的倾向。有一次，在新墨西哥州的一家靴子店里，詹姆斯走到售货员面前，当着妻子的面，请他省大家点时间，直接把店里最贵的一双鞋拿给她看。她变得非常安静，当她心烦意乱时就会这样。那一刻，你知道的，在我做了我通常会做的事之后，也就是假装那件事没发生过，而那招不管用时，
I have this thought, right? Like, I did something. I mean, she's hurt for a reason. That's like, it's not nothing. And there is something that I can do. And for me, it's coming out of this deep realization that I can ignore it. And the next three hours of our life are going to be quiet and terrible. Or I can invalidate it and say something like, you just can't take a joke.
我有这样一个想法，对吧？我做了一些事。我的意思是，她受伤是有原因的。这并不是无足轻重。确实有我可以做的事。对我来说，这源于一个深刻的认识：我可以选择忽视它，
And then the next three days of our life are going to be terrible. Or even though it is deep. humbling, I can say, I messed up. And so I think, if I remember correctly, what I said in that moment was, I'm sorry, I teased you in front of the salesperson. And that was, that was hurtful. And I get that. And I'm just, I'm sorry. I wish I hadn't done that. the apology is like water on dry earth. It doesn't turn the moment immediately. But if you can leave it there with sincerity, it will soak in.
然后我们生活中接下来的三个小时将会安静而糟糕。或者我可以否定它，说一些诸如“你就是开不起玩笑”之类的话。然后我们生活中接下来的三天都会很糟糕。或者，尽管这非常令人谦卑，但我可以说，我搞砸了。所以我想，如果我没记错的话，我当时说的是：“对不起，我在售货员面前取笑了你。那是，那是很伤人的。我明白。我只是，对不起。我真希望我没这么做。”道歉就像干旱大地上的水。它不会立即扭转局面。但如果你能真诚地把它留在那儿，它就会渗透进去。
And so it takes a few minutes, but then my wife is able to turn to me and say, I know you didn't mean it. Thank you for apologizing. I offered, like, do you want to just leave and go someplace else? And she said, no, let's stay. Let's look at what they've got. And things were a little tender between the two of us for, you know, the next 15 or 20 minutes. But then that playfulness, that connection just reemerged, right?
所以这需要几分钟的时间，然后我的妻子能够转向我说：“我知道你不是那个意思。谢谢你道歉。”我主动提出：“你想直接离开去别的地方吗？”她说：“不，留下来吧。看看他们有什么。”我们俩之间有点尴尬，你知道的，持续了接下来的15或 20 分钟。但随后那种顽皮、那种连接又重新出现了，对吧？
And so these things aren't like switching a light switch. They're more like creating the condition. under which connection can reoccur. And so, of course, the challenge is it is humbling to apologize. But eating the blame creates the conditions under which we repair and reconnect and move relatively quickly back into that place where we both feel that sense of loving connection and playfulness. One of the things I'm taking away from what you're saying, James, is that when we put
所以这些事情不像是按一下电灯开关。它们更像是创造了条件，让连接能够再次发生。所以，当然，挑战在于道歉是令人谦卑的。但“吃下责怪”创造了这样的条件：在这些条件下，我们得以修复、重新连接，并相对迅速地回到那种我们俩都能感受到爱的连接和顽皮嬉戏的地方。詹姆斯，我从你所说的话中吸取的教训之一是，当我们把
ourselves in the position of being the first to apologize or the first to try and reach out or the first to try and understand rather than be understood, in some ways this involves humbling ourselves. Can you talk about the idea that one thing that keeps us and mesh? in conflict is pride? It is pride. Our ego is not our friend in our intimate relationship. And oftentimes the fight, like we were talking about earlier, the fight to be understood, the fight to get you to accept the blame is a way in which we are defending our ego and
自己放在第一个道歉、第一个试图伸出援手、或者第一个试图去理解而不是被理解的位置时，在某种程度上这涉及到谦卑自己。你能谈谈这个观点吗：让我们陷入冲突无法自拔的原因之一是骄傲？确实是骄傲。我们的自我（Ego）在亲密关系中并不是我们的朋友。而且很多时候，争吵——就像我们刚才讨论的那样，为了被理解而争吵，为了让你承认错误而争吵——是我们保卫自我的一种方式，
our ego is protecting our vulnerability, I call it lowering the ego flag. When we are able to embrace that sense of defensiveness that is our egotism and to recognize that it's actually okay for me to be vulnerable in this moment, I don't need my ego to defend me right now, then we find our way to a place where we can be so much more skillful in relation to our partner. And it's hard because oftentimes, you know, like let's be honest, the thing that my partner is saying to me, I don't want to hear, right? It's a criticism of me. It's a complaint about me. They might be saying it from a place of anger. And so I feel attacked. And I want to attack back or I want to run away or I want to defend myself. But the true intimacy practice,
而我们的自我正在保护我们的脆弱，我称之为“降下自我之旗”。当我们能够拥抱那种代表着我们自负的防御心理，并认识到此刻展现脆弱其实是可以的，我不需要我的自我此刻来捍卫我时，我们就能找到一条通往更熟练地处理与伴侣关系的道路。这很难，因为很多时候，老实说，伴侣对我说的话，我不想听，对吧？这是对我的批评。这是对我的抱怨。他们说话时可能带着愤怒。所以我感到受到了攻击。我想反击，或者我想逃跑，或者我想为自己辩护。但真正的亲密关系修行，
The true spiritual practice is if I can meet my partner's upset, even if it's anger, with a sense of empathy. Like, something's hurting you. And that's why you're reacting to me with complaint, with anger, with criticism. And if I can reach through the anger to speak to the thing that hurts, then we're going to find ourselves in a much better place in our relationship. 10, 15 minutes from now, than if I'm just reacting to your anger. But that is deeply humbling to be able to sort of take someone else's upset and just absorb it. Like, you're upset.
真正的精神修行是，如果我能用同理心去面对伴侣的心烦意乱，即使那是愤怒。“有什么事伤害了你。这就是为什么你用抱怨、愤怒、批评来对付我。”如果我能透过愤怒去触及那个受伤的东西，那么在从现在起10到15分钟后，我们会发现我们的关系处于一个好得多的状态，而不是仅仅对你的愤怒做出反应。但能够把别人的心烦意乱拿来并完全吸收它，是极其谦卑的。就像：“你心烦意乱。
I can handle that. I can practice seeing through that to the hurt that that's based in. And we can often do that much more instinctively with our children. If our five-year-old comes to us ferociously angry, we don't get into a ferociously angry fight with them. We recognize that the anger is rooted in some kind of pain, and we try to address the pain. If we can bring that same compassionately loving attitude to our partners, then we're really cooking with fire. One of the interesting points that you just made is that our defensiveness often comes from a place of wanting to protect our own vulnerabilities. Our defensiveness can then come out as aggression, as blame, but it's interesting that these things that feel like they're very angry and outward focused are actually often a form of protecting ourselves from pain.
我能应付。我可以练习透过它看到它所基于的伤害。”我们对孩子往往能更本能地做到这一点。如果我们的五岁孩子怒气冲冲地跑来，我们不会跟他们大发雷霆。我们认识到愤怒植根于某种痛苦，然后我们试着去解决痛苦。如果我们能把这种充满同情和爱意的态度带给我们的伴侣，那我们可就真的渐入佳境了。你刚才提出的一点很有趣，那就是我们的防御心理往往源于想要保护我们自己的脆弱。我们的防御心理随后可能会表现为攻击、指责，但有趣的是，这些感觉非常愤怒且向外关注的事情，实际上往往是一种保护我们免受痛苦的形式。
They're actually a form of fear, if you will. We might be venturing far from the terrain that you usually cover. This might be more philosophy than psychology. But could you just talk about this idea that in some ways, much of what we see in terms of antipathy and aggression in relationships is often coming from a place of vulnerability and fear? That's actually right at the heart of it. The way that I talked to couples about this is it's so easy for us.
它们实际上是一种恐惧，如果你愿意这么说的话。我们可能会偏离你通常涉足的领域。这可能更多是哲学而不是心理学。但你能谈谈这个观点吗：在某种程度上，我们在关系中看到的大部分反感和攻击，往往都源于脆弱和恐惧？这其实正是核心所在。我和伴侣们讨论这一点的方式是，这太容易发生在我们的身上了。
We are made exquisitely vulnerable in our long-term, intimate relationships. Nobody's going to hurt us as often, mostly by accident, or as deeply as the person that we have opened ourselves up to the most completely. And the way that we respond to being hurt is to give ourselves over to our bodyguards. So we, we, We have these angry, blaming, critical parts of who we are whose job is to protect our vulnerability. So when we feel our vulnerability gets stung, our bodyguards come piling out of the back room to beat the heck out of the person that hurt us. Unfortunately, more often that not, that's our partner, who we actually want to be in a long-term loving, safe-making relationship with. my bodyguards go after my partner that hurts her then her bodyguards go after my bodyguards
在长期的亲密关系中，我们变得异常脆弱。没有人会像那个我们完全向其敞开心扉的人那样，经常（大多是偶然地）或深深地伤害我们。而我们对受到伤害的反应是将自己交给我们的保镖。所以我们，我们，我们有这些愤怒、指责、挑剔的人格部分，他们的工作是保护我们的脆弱。所以当我们感到脆弱受到刺痛时，我们的保镖就会从后面的房间蜂拥而出，痛打那个伤害我们的人。不幸的是，更多时候，那是我们的伙伴，是我们真正想要与之建立长期、充满爱、提供安全感的关系的人。我的保镖去追赶伤害她的伴侣，然后她的保镖去追赶我的保镖
and now our bodyguards are in a fight but we're out of communication with each other and and those bodyguards like I love my bodyguards like and they love me that's why they fight so ferociously to protect me but I can't let them run the store my bodyguards don't know how to count money right They don't know how to do good customer service. The only thing they know how to do is how to punch people and throw them out the door, right? So if I'm going to be in a long-term, intimate, safe-making relationship with my partner, I need to be the boss of my bodyguards.
现在我们的保镖陷入了一场争斗，但我们彼此之间失去了沟通，而这些保镖——我爱我的保镖——它们也爱我，这就是为什么它们如此拼命地保护我，但我不能让它们当家作主。我的保镖不懂得怎么数钱，对吧？他们不知道如何做好客户服务。他们唯一懂的就是如何痛扁别人并把他们扔出门外，对吧？所以，如果我要与伴侣建立一段长期的、亲密的、提供安全感的关系，我需要成为我保镖的老板。
So when they come piling out of the back room, I need to be able to come up behind my bodyguard and put my hand on his shoulder and say, I know you're just trying to keep me safe, buddy, but I've got this. You talked a second ago about the importance of eating the blame and actually reaching out to someone when we feel like we should be reached out to. Does this reaching out have to be sincere, James, by which I mean when your partner is hurt, do you actually have to feel their pain,
所以当他们从后面的房间蜂拥而出时，我需要能够走到我的保镖身后，把手搭在他的肩膀上说：“我知道你只是想保护我，伙计，但这由我来接管。”詹姆斯，你刚才谈到了“吃下责怪”的重要性，以及在觉得应该由对方主动时主动向某人伸出援手。这种伸出援手必须是真诚的吗，詹姆斯？我的意思是，当你的伴侣受伤时，你真的必须感受到他们的痛苦，
or is it enough to say that you wish that you could feel their pain or say that you wish that they were less sad or say that you are sorry, do you actually have to mean all those things? I love the question because sometimes we can genuinely feel and empathize and have like a natural compassion for the pain that our partners experience. And sometimes we just can't. We're caught up in our own stuff. We can't understand well enough yet to really be able to.
还是说只要说希望自己能感受到他们的痛苦，或者说希望他们不要那么难过，或者说一声对不起就足够了？你必须真心实意地对待所有这些事情吗？我喜欢这个问题，因为有时我们可以真诚地感受到并产生同理心，对伴侣经历的痛苦抱有一种自然的同情。而有时我们做不到。我们陷入了自己的事情中。我们还无法足够好地理解，从而真正能够
to resonate with where they're coming from. So I guess I would say it's not so much that we have to mean it as that we have to be authentic. So I think if we're being inauthentically apologetic, we are very skilled at seeing through inauthenticity. Inauthentic apologies never work. But if we're being authentic about I really don't understand, but I want to.
与他们的心境产生共鸣。所以我想我会说，这与其说我们必须是真心实意的，不如说我们必须是真实的。所以我想，如果我们虚假地道歉，我们非常善于看穿虚假。虚假的道歉永远不管用。但如果我们对“我真的不理解，但我很想理解”保持真实，
I really can't feel my way into what's hurting you, but I wish I could. Then that matters. Sometimes the thing that matters most to us is that the other person just cares, even if they're having a hard time getting to the place that we need them to get. When we come back, we're all used to prosecuting our side of the argument in conflicts with partners. What happens when we prosecute their side? That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
如果我们对“我真的无法感同身受你受到的伤害，但我希望我能”保持真实。那么这就很重要。有时对我们最重要的是对方真的在乎，即使他们很难达到我们需要的状态。休息过后，我们都习惯于在与伴侣的冲突中为自己的一方辩护。当我们为对方的一方辩护时会发生什么？稍后揭晓。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. What have you learned about changing your partner in the course of your relationship? Have you come up with ways to accept your partner's flaws? If you have questions or comments you'd like to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a short voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, acceptance. James Cordova is a psychologist at Clark University. He is the author of The Mindful Path to Intimacy,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在你们的关系中，关于改变伴侣，你学到了什么？你有没有想出接受伴侣缺点的方法？如果你有任何问题或评论想与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享，请在手机上录制一段简短的语音备忘录，并将其通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas at hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行：接纳。詹姆斯·科尔多瓦是克拉克大学的心理学家。他是《通往亲密关系的觉察之路》一书的作者，
cultivating a deeper connection with your partner. James, you say one step to get us closer to accepting our partners as they are is to identify what you call understandable reasons for why our partners do what they do. What does it mean to find an understandable reason? So none of us, you know, do the things that we do for no reason at all. And it is often hard for us as a partner to, like all we know is that the thing that you're doing is hurting me, the thing that you're doing is bothering me or irritating me. And that's very much a surface level understanding.
这本书讲述了如何与伴侣建立更深层次的连接。詹姆斯，你说让我们更接近于接受本来的伴侣的一个步骤，是找出你所说的“伴侣为什么会这样做”的可理解原因。找到一个可理解原因意味着什么？所以我们所有人，你知道的，做我们所做的事情都不是毫无理由的。而且作为伴侣，我们通常很难做到——我们所知道的只是你正在做的事情正在伤害我，你正在做的事情正在困扰我或激怒我。这很大程度上是一种表层理解。
And we're often reacting to the surface level. What I've found in working with couples over and over again is if we can bring to what we see is the problematic behavior of our partner, a sort of loving curiosity that allows us to dig for, help me to understand where this is coming from you, why this feels so important, what it's rooted in, that much more often than not, we find our way to a place where our experience is, oh, that's why you do this. So I'm thinking of an example where one partner would very fussily at the end of the day go around, like,
而我们往往对表层做出反应。我在一遍又一遍地与伴侣合作时发现的是，如果我们能对我们所看到的伴侣成问题的行为抱有一种充满爱意的求知欲，让我们去挖掘——“帮我理解这从何而来，为什么这感觉如此重要，它植根于什么”——那么往往我们会找到这样一种途径：我们的体验是，“哦，原来这就是你这样做的原因。”所以我想到了这样一个例子：一个伴侣在一天结束时会非常大惊小怪地四处查看，
like, checking that all of the windows were locked and all of the doors were locked. And his complaint was, I don't know why I'm the only one in the household who cares, right, about this. And, you know, his partner, you know, was just looking at him, like, I don't know why you have to be so crazy about everything being locked. And they would, you know, have multiple arguments about this. What, what we, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, was to ask him was to ask him, was there. ever a time when not having the house locked up actually resulted in something that was scary or hard for you. And he was able to tell the story about when he was young, I think like five years old, their house had gotten broken into, and one of his favorite toys had gotten stolen.
比如，检查所有的窗户是否都锁好了，所有的门是否都锁好了。他的抱怨是：“我不知道为什么我是家里唯一一个关心这个的人。”而且，你知道的，他的伙伴，你知道的，只是看着他，就像是：“我不知道为什么你对每件事都要锁上这般疯狂。”而且他们会，你知道的，为此进行多次争论。我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们的做法是问他，问他，有没有
Like, not just like I loved playing with it, but like I loved it. I think it was like a teddy bear, right like my teddy bear that i loved and brought me so much comfort was was stolen during this this break in and and he sort of realized like oh that's that's where i'm coming from and as he was telling the story you could see the aha moment on his partner's face that sense of oh that's why you do that right and so it shifted from why are you so crazy about this to oh i get it right and again, what I found over and over again is compassion is effortless. It's not something that we have to bootstrap under the right conditions. When we get to this place where, like, I see the understandable reason for why you do this, compassion just very naturally emerges.
曾经有那么一次，没有把房子锁好实际上导致了让你感到害怕或困难的事情。他能够讲述这样一个故事：当他年轻的时候，我想大约五岁的时候，他们的家曾遭到入室盗窃，他最喜欢的一个玩具被偷了。不是那种“我喜欢玩它”，而是那种“我爱它”。我想那就像是一只泰迪熊，对吧，就像我深爱的、带给我极多安慰的泰迪熊在这次入室盗窃中被偷了。他突然意识到，“哦，原来这就是我心态的来源。”当他讲述这个故事时，你可以在他伴侣的脸上看到恍然大悟的时刻，那种“哦，原来这就是你这样做的原因”的感觉。所以它从“你为什么对这个这么疯狂”变成了“哦，我明白了”。再次强调，我一次又一次发现的是，同情心是不费吹灰之力的。在适当的条件下，它不是我们需要勉强维持的东西。当我们到达这个地方，就像我看到了你这样做的可理解原因时，同情心就会非常自然地涌现出来。
I have to ask, why would someone. I have to ask, why would someone? someone break into a house and steal a teddy bear? It's a really good question. I feel like I wish I had followed up, like, who broke into your house and why did they steal your teddy bear? Those thieves need some therapy, James. I think the thieves need some help there. Exactly. You've written about a couple that you worked with.
我不得不问，为什么有人。我不得不问，为什么有人。会闯入民宅偷一只泰迪熊？这是一个很好的问题。我觉得我真希望我当时追问了，比如，是谁闯入了你家，他们为什么偷你的泰迪熊？那些小偷需要做心理治疗，詹姆斯。我想那些小偷确实需要一些帮助。完全正确。你写过一对你曾合作过的伴侣。
You call them Mike and Susan. They were able to move toward accepting one another once they identified, understandable reasons for why each was acting in a certain way. Can you tell me Mike and Susan's story? Yeah, I love thinking about this couple because they were ultimately such a beautiful couple, but in this couple, Mike is, he gets home earlier, right, than Susan. And he's the cook in the family, he takes great pride in it,
你称他们为迈克和苏珊。一旦他们确定了各自以某种特定方式行事的“可理解原因”，他们就能够朝着互相接纳迈进。你能给我讲讲迈克和苏珊的故事吗？是的，我很喜欢回想这对伴侣，因为他们最终是一对如此美好的伴侣。但在这对伴侣中，迈克，他比苏珊回家得早，对吧。他是家里的厨师，他为此感到非常自豪，
and he loves it, one of the things that feels most connecting to him, him is when Susan shows up from work on time and they can have dinner together in this sweet sort of romantic way. Susan is committed to her job. It is something that she has worked hard to sort of accomplish. And when she's there, she's very single-minded about it. And so it's not uncommon for her to get a little bit of a late start coming home. And of course, given where we live, you get a little bit of a late start, you're going to get home really late because you're going to get stuck in traffic. And so the conflict that would arise between the two of them is she'd get home late. He would be hurt and angry and, you know, either have put the food away already or it's sitting out on the table cold and he's fussy about it.
并且他非常喜欢这样。对他而言，最能建立亲密感的事情之一，就是苏珊准时下班回家，然后两人以一种甜蜜又浪漫的方式一起吃晚餐。苏珊对她的工作非常投入。这是她通过努力才取得的成就。当她工作时，她会非常专注。因此，她下班晚一点也是常有的事。当然，鉴于我们居住的地方，只要稍微晚一会儿出发，你就会很晚才到家，因为你会遇上交通堵塞。因此，两人之间产生的矛盾就是：她回家晚了。他会感到受伤和愤怒，你知道的，要么已经把饭菜收起来了，要么就让它凉在桌上，而且他会为此感到斤斤计较。
And she's feeling like you don't care about how important my work is to me. And so he's desperate for, I need to know where you are. I need to know what your timing is. I need for you to take seriously how important these moments in the evening are to me. And she's desperate for that sense of you care about how much effort I've put into, how much I've sacrificed to be able to do this kind of work. How do they come to a better understanding than their initial conflict, James? Again, as with most couples, the path towards a deeper intimacy is a willingness to really hear
而她的感受则是：你根本不在乎我的工作对我有多重要。因此，他迫切地想要知道：我需要知道你在哪里。我需要知道你的时间安排。我需要你认真对待傍晚这些时刻对我的重要性。而她则迫切渴望感受到：你在乎我为了能够从事这种工作付出了多少努力、做出了多少牺牲。詹姆斯，他们究竟如何才能达成比最初冲突时更好的理解呢？同大多数伴侣一样，通往更深层亲密关系之路，在于愿意去真正倾听
and compassionately understand where the other person is coming from, which to the point that we were making earlier requires for us to and required for them to let go just for a moment of the need to get the other person to understand. So when Mike could let go of how hard he was fighting to get her to understand how important these moments in the evening were for him and to really hear her and to think about and remember all of their shared experience of how much sacrifice she had put into, how much joy, how much meaning she gets out of her work, and the fact that sometimes traffic just is what it is, then he was better able to understand, okay, you're not doing this to me.
并带着同理心去理解对方的出发点。这就正如我们刚才所提到的，需要我们——也需要他们——暂时放下那种非要让对方理解自己的迫切需求。因此，当迈克能够放下他先前那种强烈的抗争——不再急于让苏珊明白傍晚这些时刻对他是多么重要——而是去真正倾听苏珊，去思考并记起他们共同经历过的那些事：她为这项工作付出了多少牺牲、从中获得了多少快乐和意义，以及有时交通状况确实就是那样无法改变，那么他就更能理解：“好吧，你并不是故意针对我。”
It's not a deliberate insult or a deliberate lack of care. It is, like we were saying before, it's sort of the beauty of the dumpster fire that is my workaholic wife. And when she was able to understand and to almost envision what it's like to be home early, you're making this meal, you're anticipating this lovely moment, you're sort of like the dog with the tail wag going, like, oh, I can't wait for my wife to come home, and then it's six, and then it's six-thirty, and then it's seven, and just the deflation and the upset that comes with that, then she was, again, in a better position to feel like he's not. mad at me. He's just disappointed. And that disappointed is actually rooted in how connected he is to
这不是故意侮辱，也不是故意漠不关心。就像我们刚才说的，这某种程度上就是我这个工作狂妻子所带来的那场“垃圾桶之火”的美丽之处。而当她能够理解并几乎在脑海中想象出这样一幅画面：你在家里早早做好饭，满怀期待地等待着这个美好的时刻，就像一只摇着尾巴的小狗一样想着：“哦，我迫不及待想让妻子回家了，”结果到了六点没回来，接着是六点半，然后是七点，随之而来的只有那种泄气和沮丧时，她也就处于了一种更好的状态，能够感觉到：他并没有生我的气。他只是失望。而这种失望，其实根源于他同我之间
me. One of the enduring patterns that has come up over and over in this conversation we've been having James is that when people do things that disappoint us, we often don't just see the behavior. We read intention into that behavior. So in other words, in this case, Susan is not just saying, you know, Mike is upset because he made a nice dinner and we couldn't have it together. Susan's saying, Mike is just such a fussy person. We're having dinner at 7 o'clock instead of 6 o'clock. What's the big deal? And Mike is not just saying Susan's busy at work. It takes her time to get home. Mike is saying Susan doesn't care about me. He's reading intention into Susan's behavior. Can you talk about how quickly we believe we can read what's happening in other people?
有着多么紧密的联系。詹姆斯，在我们一直以来的这场对话中，有一个不断反复出现的持久模式：当人们做出让我们失望的事情时，我们往往不仅仅只是看到他们的行为。我们会将某种意图解读到那些行为当中。换句话说，在这个例子中，苏珊并不只是在想：“你知道的，迈克很难过，因为他做了顿丰盛的晚餐，而我们没能一起吃。”苏珊心里想的是：“迈克这个人怎么这么爱挑剔。我们只是把晚饭时间从六点改到七点而已，这算什么大不了的事？”而迈克也不只是在想：“苏珊工作很忙，她需要时间才能回家。”迈克心里想的是：“苏珊根本不在乎我。”他在苏珊的行为中解读出了某种意图。你能谈谈为什么我们总觉得自己能如此迅速地看穿
people's minds. And even when we're wrong, this belief that we have that the other person has it in for us now makes us very upset, makes us very angry. It's an intuitive thing that we do. Like, I'm feeling not cared for. And the internal emotional logic is therefore that means that you don't care. And that happens so quickly. It's got so much automaticity to it that if I'm not feeling cared for, you must have done that on purpose. And it takes more time, more effort, more deliberateness to feel our way through that just because I'm feeling like you did that on purpose. Doesn't necessarily mean that you did that on purpose. Let me take that extra five minutes. Again, a somewhat humility-based move
别人的心思吗？而且，即便我们猜错了，我们这种认为“对方是冲着我们来”的信念，也会让我们感到非常沮丧、非常愤怒。这是我们下意识会做的一种反应。比如：“我觉得自己没有被关心。”而内在的情感逻辑紧接着就会得出结论：“因此，这意味着你根本不在乎。”这种反应发生得太快了。它具有如此高度的自动化，以至于如果我感觉不到被关心，你一定就是故意的。我们需要花更多的时间、付出更多精力、拿出更多的审慎，才能去梳理这种情绪——仅仅因为我觉得你是故意的，并不一定意味着你当时就是故意的。让我多给自己五分钟时间吧。这同样是一种基于某种谦逊的做法
to remind myself that my partner loves me, they would almost never do anything intentionally to hurt me. What might be another hypothesis for why they're doing, what they're doing? But the challenge for us is that that doesn't ever become, oh, I didn't have the experience of you did that on purpose. That can only become, oh, I'm having the experience that you did that on purpose. and now I'm having to complicate it. You say that many couples complain about having to be too sensitive to their partner's sore spots.
来提醒我自己：我的伴侣是爱我的，他们几乎绝不可能故意做出任何伤害我的事。对于他们正在做的事，会不会还有另一种假设呢？但对我们而言，挑战在于这从来不会变成：“哦，我不再体验到你是故意这么做的了。”它只能变成：“哦，我正体验到你是故意这么做的，而现在我不得不去理清这背后的复杂情绪。”你说过，许多伴侣抱怨说，他们必须对伴侣的痛处过于敏感。
They complain about having to walk on eggshells. What do you tell them? The metaphor that I use for couples about the inescapability of each other's vulnerability is that there is a moment in our relationship where my partner is inviting me into their vulnerability. They're inviting me into their China shop and I am the bull. So they are inviting the bull into their China shop and I'm inviting their bull into my China shop. And that's a way of getting at like we are both exquisitely vulnerable to each other. And there is a part of us that wishes that in the desire to be our full-throated authentic selves, we could just toss our
他们抱怨自己不得不战战兢兢、如履薄冰。你对他们有什么建议？我用来向伴侣们解释“彼此的脆弱无法逃避”这个概念的比喻是：在我们的关系中，总会有这样一个时刻：我的伴侣邀请我走入他们的脆弱之中。他们邀请我进入他们的瓷器店，而我就是那头公牛。所以，他们邀请公牛进入他们的瓷器店，而我也在邀请他们的公牛进入我的瓷器店。这是一种用来理解以下事实的方式：我们对彼此都极其脆弱。在我们内心深处，总有一个部分幻想着：为了能够展现最彻底、最真实的自我，每当我们感到沮丧时，我们就可以随心所欲地挥舞着
horns around whenever we felt upset and our partner would just meet that with great grace and generosity but we can't if somebody has invited you into the places where they are most fragile you have accepted the responsibility to be a mindful thoughtful careful bull in their china shop And you never get to just toss your head around. And that is, that does require a quality of care and thoughtfulness and deliberateness. And we often wish we didn't have to. We wish we could just, like when I'm mad, I wish I could just act out. But I know if I'm paying attention that if I do that,
自己的角，而我们的伴侣本该以极大的优雅和宽容来包容这一切。但我们不能这样做。如果某人已经邀请你走入了他们最脆弱的地方，你就承担起了一份责任：要做他们瓷器店里一个正念的、体贴的、小心的公牛。你绝不能再由着自己的性子胡乱挥舞脑袋。这确实需要一种关怀、体贴和审慎的品质。我们常常希望自己不必如此。我们希望自己可以随心所欲——比如当我生气时，我希望自己能够直接宣泄出来。但我知道，只要我留心，如果我真的那样做了，
I'm going to cause harm. And so my responsibility is always to take good and loving care of my partner's china shop. I mean, in some ways, it's like saying, you know, if you've been given the privilege of attending, you know, a wonderful concert recital, and you're in a quiet hall,
我就会造成伤害。因此，我的责任始终是好好地、充满爱意地照顾好我伴侣的瓷器店。我的意思是，从某种意义上说，这就好比是说：你知道的，如果你获得了出席某个美妙音乐会的特权，而且你身处一个安静的大厅里，
there's certain obligations that come with that privilege. You can't actually let your phone run off in the middle of the show. You can't jump up and have a tirade about the performers. There are some rules that come with this privilege. Right, exactly.
伴随着这种特权而来的，必然是某些义务。你实际上不能在演出进行到一半时让手机铃声大作。你不能突然跳起来对表演者大发雷霆。伴随这种特权而来的，必然有一些规则。没错，确实如此。
So, and it can be something really, really, like, blameless, right? Like, I've got a cough. Well, if I have a cough and I'm coughing uncontrollably, I can't be here right now. Right? have to take responsibility for the privilege of the space that I've been invited into, right? If right now I'm too angry to behave gently, then I can't be here right now.
所以，这也可以是非常非常小的事情，比如毫无责备意味的事情，对吧？比如：我咳嗽了。好吧，如果我咳嗽而且咳得停不下来，那我现在就不能待在这里了。对吧？我必须对被邀请进入这个空间的特权承担责任，对吧？如果此刻我的愤怒已经大到无法表现得温和，那么我现在就不能待在这里。
And that's how I respect the privilege that I've been offered of being so close to your vulnerability. couples often complain to you that their partners have changed, that they are no longer the people they once were. Can you talk about this, James, and how people should address this concern? There is a part of us that wishes our partner wouldn't change, that wishes we wouldn't change, that wishes the world wouldn't change. And I think of it as like a two-dimensional cardboard cutout of who we want our partner to be or who we imagine our partner. partner to be so that we can get that sense of stability and behind that two-dimensional cardboard cut out our partner is already somebody else and the real gift of a vibrant
这就是我如何尊重别人赋予我的特权——能够如此贴近你们的脆弱。伴侣们经常向你抱怨说他们的伙伴变了，他们已经不再是当年那个人了。詹姆斯，你能谈谈这个现象吗？人们应该如何应对这种担忧？在我们内心深处，总有一个部分希望伴侣不要改变，希望自己不要改变，希望世界不要改变。我将这视为我们对伴侣的一种二维纸板剪影——也就是我们希望伴侣成为的样子，或者我们想象中的伴侣，
intimate relationship is surrendering to the the constantly emerging change that is who we are together and who we are becoming together. There's some parts of us that we are constantly becoming something new. And, of course, there's a part of us that continues to be familiar. You know, take my partner, for example, you know, every day there's something new that she's learned. There's some new way that she's becoming. She's just started throwing pottery for the first time, which is a delightful, and as it turns out, It requires a lot of skill.
以便从中获得那种安全感。而在那个二维纸板剪影的背后，我们的伴侣其实早已经变成了另一个人。一段充满活力、亲密的真正礼物，在于臣服于那种不断涌现的变化——正是这种变化构成了我们在一起时的模样，以及我们共同成长塑造成的模样。我们身上的某些部分正在不断变成崭新的事物。当然，我们身上也确实有一部分会保持着熟悉感。你知道的，以我的伴侣为例，你知道的，每天都有她学到的新东西。她正在以某种崭新的方式不断成长。她最近刚刚开始第一次学习陶艺，这是一件令人愉悦的事，而且事实证明，这需要花费很多技巧。
So this is a learning curve for her. And that tenderheartedness that I first fell in love with, that's not going anywhere. And when I can remember that, that is also something that is unique and beautiful and, again, vibrantly alive in the moment because what that tenderheartedness is meeting each day is always something new. One theme that runs through much of James Cordova's work is that we should think about the health of our relationships the same way we think about our physical health. We should get regular evaluations and stay vigilant to problems.
所以对她来说，这是一个学习曲线。而当初让我坠入爱河的那种柔情，并没有消失。当我能想起这一点时，我就会明白：这也是一种独特而美丽的东西，而且再次说明，它在当下是充满生机与活力的，因为这种柔情每天所面对的，永远都是崭新的事物。贯穿詹姆斯·科尔多瓦（James Cordova）大部分研究的一个主题是：我们应该像看待身体健康一样来看待关系的健康。我们应该定期进行评估，并对可能出现的问题保持警惕。
In our companion story on Hidden Brain Plus that was published a few days ago, we explored a series of questions that James suggests couples ask themselves to evaluate the strengths and weaknesses of their relationships. Spotting problems early can allow you to fix problems before they become intractable. Our companion episode was called How Strong is Your Marriage? If you're a subscriber, you can listen to that episode and all of our subscriber-only content immediately. If you haven't yet signed up, go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.com.
在我们几天前发布的《隐藏的大脑PLUS》（Hidden Brain Plus）配套故事中，我们探讨了一系列詹姆斯建议伴侣们问自己的问题，以此来评估他们关系的强项与弱点。及早发现问题，能让你在问题变得棘手之前将其解决。我们的这期配套节目名为《你的婚姻有多牢固？》。如果你是订阅用户，你可以立即收听该期节目以及我们所有仅限订阅用户观看的内容。如果你还没有注册，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.com
slash hidden brain. Your support helps us bring you more episodes like this one. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org and apple.com slash hidden brain. After the break, your questions answered. Researcher Vicks Trecker returns to the show to respond to listeners' thoughts and questions about how to find and maintain their purpose in life.
/hidden brain。你的支持帮助我们为你带来更多像这样的节目。再次重申，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org 以及 apple.com/hidden brain。休息之后，我们将回答你的问题。研究员维克斯·特雷克（Vix Strecker）重返节目，回应听众关于如何找到并保持人生目标的种种想法与疑问。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. From the time where children were asked, what do you want to be when you grow up? This question contains a multitude of other questions. What do you care about? What are you good at?
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。从孩子们被问到“你长大后想做什么？”的时候起，这个问题就包含了无数其他的问题。你在乎什么？你擅长什么？
What makes you happy? As we get older, we find ourselves asking an even more complex question. What is my purpose in life? At the University of Michigan, Victor Strecker has pondered this question for many years. In this edition of your questions answered, we've asked Vic to respond to listeners' thoughts and questions about how to live a more purposeful, meaningful life. If you missed our earlier episodes with Vic,
什么能让你快乐？随着年龄的增长，我们发现自己在问一个更加复杂的问题：我的人生目标是什么？在密歇根大学（University of Michigan），维克托·斯特雷克（Victor Strecker）多年来一直在思考这个问题。在本期“你的问题解答”中，我们请维克来回应听众关于如何过上有目标、有意义的生活的种种想法与疑问。如果你错过了我们先前与维克的节目，
you can find them in this podcast feed. The first is called U2.0, What is Your Life for? And the second, found on Hidden Brain Plus, is called U2.0, the power of finding purpose. Vic Strecker, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thank you very much, Shankar. Look forward to this. Vic, in our initial conversation, we talked about why purpose is so important and how having a sense of purpose can affect our health. Remind us, if you will, of what the research
你可以在本播客的动态中找到它们。第一期名为《U2.0：你的人生是为了什么？》，第二期可在《隐藏的大脑PLUS》中找到，名为《U2.0：寻找目标的力量》。维克·斯特雷克，欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢，尚卡尔。我很期待这次交流。维克，在我们最初的对话中，我们谈到了为什么目标如此重要，以及拥有目标感如何影响我们的健康。如果可以的话，请提醒我们，研究
finds about this connection, both when it comes to our mental health and our physical health. Sure. So people with a stronger purpose, direction, intentionality in their lives live longer, for one thing, and there are now at least eight, nine, ten studies showing that very carefully. There are eight studies now showing that people with strong purpose around the age of retirement are far less likely to develop dementia, which is very intriguing, really. People with strong purpose have fewer pro-inflammatory cells produced in their body. Some of my colleagues have found that people with stronger purpose are less likely to develop heart attacks. If they already are susceptible to heart attack and heart disease, they're less likely to develop stroke.
关于这种联系发现了什么，无论是在心理健康还是身体健康方面？当然。首先，有更强目标感、方向感和意向性的人活得更久，目前至少有八、九、十项研究非常仔细地证明了这一点。现在有八项研究表明，处于退休年龄左右、具有强烈目标感的人患痴呆症的可能性要小得多，这真的很吸引人。有强烈目标感的人，体内产生的促炎细胞较少。我的一些同事发现，目标感更强的人患心脏病的可能性较小。如果他们已经容易患心脏病和心脏疾病，他们患中风的可能性也较小。
We've found that people are less likely to be abusing drugs and medication. They're more physically active. They tend to eat better. And so maybe this is one of the explanations for why purpose helps you live longer. it's because you take care of yourself better, and why do you do that? It's because there are certain things that really matter a lot to you, and you think I better take care of myself. When we first spoke, Vic, you told me about a very important person in your life, your daughter, Julia.
我们发现，人们滥用毒品和药物的可能性较小。他们的身体更活跃。他们往往吃得更好。所以也许这就是为什么目标能帮你活得更久的解释之一：因为你把自己照顾得更好。而你为什么要这样做呢？因为有些事情对你真的很重要，你觉得我最好把自己照顾好。维克，当我们第一次交谈时，你告诉我你生命中一个非常重要的人——你的女儿茱莉亚（Julia）。
Julia had health complications that affected her heart, and she had two heart transplants, one when she was a baby and one later in childhood. Can you talk about how these experiences led Julia to find her own sense of purpose? I think when Julia went through her second heart transplant, she was conscious enough to understand that she may not live a long life. And I think as a result, she became far more purposeful. And I think that's one interesting relationship between salience of death, knowledge that you will die at some point in time, right, and having a purpose. Because you know, this isn't a practice round. This is your life, whether it's long, whether it's short. And she understood
茱莉亚有影响心脏健康的健康并发症，她做过两次心脏移植手术，一次是在她还是婴儿的时候，另一次是在童年后期。你能谈谈这些经历是如何引导茱莉亚找到她自己的人生目标的吗？我想，当茱莉亚经历第二次心脏移植时，她已经有足够的意识去明白，自己可能不会过上长寿的人生。我想正因如此，她变得更有目标感了。而且我认为，这是死亡的显着性（即知道自己在某个时间点会死这一认知）与拥有目标之间一个非常有趣的联系。因为你知道，这不是彩排。这就是你的人生，无论它是漫长还是短暂。而她明白
that she might end up living a briefer life than most of her friends. And so she took the elements of her life very seriously. She took the things that mattered most, her relationships, her friends. She had a wonderful boyfriend. She took her school very seriously. She really wanted to become a nurse. and she was passionate about being a nurse. In fact, she was passionate about everything because she knew this is the one life that she had to live. And that taught me a lot as well, frankly, about the fact that our lives are finite.
自己最终过上的生命可能比她大多数朋友都要短暂。因此，她非常认真地对待生活中的每一个要素。她抓住了最重要的事情：她的关系，她的朋友。她有一个很棒的男友。她非常认真地对待学业。她真的非常想成为一名护士，并且对成为护士充满热情。事实上，她对一切都充满热情，因为她知道这是她仅有的一次生命。坦白说，这也教给了我很多东西，关于我们的生命是有限的这一事实。
This is in practice, and we should live our lives, really almost as Stoics would talk about, where maybe every day might be our last. So as you shared in our initial conversation, Vic, Julia had a heart attack and tragically passed away at the age of 19. And you found that your daughter's life and death have shaped your own sense of purpose. I'm curious how you help people who may not have the same kind of clarity that you both found as a result of Julia's health challenges. Can you talk about
这不是彩排，我们应该过好自己的生活，几乎就像斯多葛学派所谈论的那样，也许每一天都可能是我们的最后一天。正如你在我们最初的对话中所分享的，维克，茱莉亚突发心脏病，不幸在19岁时离世。你发现女儿的生命和死亡塑造了你自己的目标感。我很好奇，对于那些可能没有你们两人因茱莉亚健康挑战而获得的同等清晰度的人，你是如何帮助他们的？你能谈谈
some of the steps you encourage people to take to find their own purpose in life? not everybody goes through some difficult tragedy and that's a good thing of course we don't want everybody to have the loss of a loved one to stimulate a person's purpose but some simple ways you might start thinking about your purpose is simply to ask yourself what matters most what are the things that are most important in my life another thing to do and we've just been talking about it is mortality salience. I have in my book, Life on Purpose, this headstone test. And it's just a real simple test. You draw a headstone any way you want, any shape you want, and put down your name, say, you just died today. And what would you want on the epitaph? What would you want people
你鼓励人们采取哪些步骤来寻找自己的人生目标吗？并不是每个人都会经历某种艰难的悲剧，这当然是一件好事，我们不希望每个人都经历失去挚爱之人的痛苦来激发一个人的目标感。但是，你可以开始思考目标的一些简单方法，就是问问自己：什么最重要？我生活中最重要的事情是什么？另一件要做的事情——我们刚才一直在谈论的——就是死亡显着性。我的书《有目的的生活》（Life on Purpose）中有一个“墓碑测试”。这只是一个非常简单的测试。你随心所欲地画一块墓碑，任何你想要的形状，写下你的名字，假设你今天刚刚去世。你希望墓志铭上写些什么？你希望人们
to say about you at your memorial service? This is really thinking about the end of your life, and it may sound depressing, but it starts getting you to think about the importance of your legacy. What do you want to leave when you've left this planet? You say that you rediscovered your purpose after Julia died by returning to teaching. Finding your purpose was a clarifying experience, and for many people, it might be a joyful process. But I can also see how it can be a little overwhelming for some people. Can you talk a little about how you navigate that balancing act?
在你的追悼会上对你说些什么？这真的是在思考你生命的终结，这听听可能让人觉得沮丧，但它开始让你思考遗产的重要性。当你离开这个星球时，你希望留下什么？你说，在茱莉亚去世后，你通过重返教书岗位重新发现了自己的目标。寻找目标是一次清晰的体验，对许多人来说，这可能是一个快乐的过程。但我也能理解，对某些人来说，它可能会让人感到有点不知所措。你能稍微谈谈你是如何驾驭这种平衡的吗？
So many people I talk to about finding their purpose are worried about the scope of their purpose or the length that they have to maintain this purpose. or even the fact that they're committing themselves to something very big and bigger than themselves very often. One of the things I like to talk about is the fact that there are different domains of purpose. I might have a work purpose. I might have a purpose at home with my family. I might have a personal purpose. I might have a community purpose.
我与之交谈过的许多寻找目标的人都担心他们目标的范围，或者他们必须维持这个目标的时长。甚至担心他们常常是在让自己致力于某件非常宏大、且大于自身的事情。我喜欢谈论的事情之一是，目标其实存在不同的领域。我可能有一个工作的目标。我可能在家里和家人有一个目标。我可能有一个个人的目标。我可能有一个社区的目标。
And you might start with these different domains of your life and ask yourself, which of those domains are most important to me. And then within that domain, you might start thinking about, do I have a purpose within that domain? For example, we spend most of our waking hours working. Most of us do anyway. So that's a really important time for many people. And many people might think, well, I just worked for the money.
你可以从生活中的这些不同领域开始，问问自己：这些领域中哪一个对我是最重要的？然后在该领域内，你可以开始思考：在这个领域内我是否有目标？例如，我们醒着的大多数时间都在工作。无论如何，我们大多数人都是如此。所以对许多人来说，这是一段非常重要的时间。许多人可能会想，我工作只是为了钱。
But are there other things that you could build in what some of my colleagues called job crafting? Could you craft purpose out of the job that you have? and turn that into something that's a little more powerful and meaningful for you during this time you're spending most of your waking hours. We received a question about the relationship between purpose and burnout. It comes from listener Valentina. She says the last nine years of her career as an educator were really hard on her.
但有没有其他事情是你可以建立的——我的一些同事称之为“工作重塑”（job crafting）？你能不能从你现有的工作中塑造出目标感？并在你醒着的大多数时间里，把它变成对你来说更有力量、更有意义的事情。我们收到一个关于“目标与职业倦怠”之间关系的问题。它来自听众瓦伦蒂娜（Valentina）。她说，她作为一名教育工作者的职业生涯最后九年对她来说非常艰难。
Here she is. I have been struggling figuring out what is next for me. I just saw a coffee mug recently that says, said, if I died and went straight to hell, it would take me a week to realize I wouldn't still be at work. That for me sums up the horrible school year I've had. I'd like to figure out how to get started finding my next chapter and my life's purpose. So it sounds like Valentina's original life purpose burned her out, Vic. How can she find new ways to identify purpose in her life? And how do you know when you need a new purpose versus needing a new setting in which to work on your old purpose?
她在这里。我一直在努力弄清楚我的下一步是什么。我最近刚看到一个咖啡杯，上面写着：“如果我死了直接下去了地狱，我要花上一周时间才会意识到我其实没有在工作。”对我来说，这总结了我度过的这个可怕的学年。我想弄清楚如何开始寻找我的下一篇章和人生的目标。听起来瓦伦蒂娜最初的人生目标让她筋疲力尽了，维克。她该如何找到新的途径来确定她生活中的目标？当你知道自己需要一个新的目标，而不是需要一个新的工作环境来继续你旧的目标时，你又是如何判断的呢？
So let's talk about two aspects of this question. One is the fact that she got burned out from teaching. And that's not uncommon because it's such a difficult job. People who are in health care get burned out from that. You see burnout everywhere. And along with burnout comes loss of purpose. So one thing I'd like to say to this person and to other people who are experiencing burnout is purpose can give you vitality and energy if you start thinking about new ways of teaching or new ways of practicing medicine or nursing. But also there are things you can do that purpose people tend to do to develop that energy and vitality.
那么，让我们来谈谈这个问题两个方面的。一方面是她因教书而筋疲力尽。这并不罕见，因为这是一份如此艰难的工作。从事医疗保健的人也会因此精疲力竭。你到处都能看到职业倦怠。伴随着倦怠而来的，是目标感的丧失。所以我想对这个人以及其他正在经历职业倦怠的人说的一件事是：如果你开始思考新的教学方式或实践医学、护理的新方式，目标可以赋予你活力与能量。但同时，你也可以做一些有目标的人往往会做的事情，来培养这种能量和活力。
I like to think of about five things that have been shown in randomized trials to actually give you more energy and vitality. One is sleep. The second is presence or mindfulness. Activity, physical activity is important. I try to walk to work every single day that I'm teaching. Creativity, you might think, what is there about creativity that gives you more energy? Well, just try doing a haiku and ask yourself, now do I have a little more energy? I asked my students to do that, and invariably, they are more vital after they just finished
我喜欢想到随机试验表明实际上能赋予你更多能量和活力的五件事。第一是睡眠。第二是当下的觉察或正念。活动，体育活动很重要。我尽我教书的每一天都步行上下班。创造力，你可能会想，创造力有什么能给你带来更多能量的地方？好吧，试着做一首俳句，然后问自己：“现在我是否有一点更多能量了？”我让我的学生这样做，无一例外，在他们刚完成
a haiku, and they all raise their hand. I want to read my haiku. The last factor Vic and other researchers are found that leads to increased vitality, and therefore purpose, is eating well. Combine this with the other four factors, and you get an acronym that Vic likes to call space. So if you are burning out as an employee or just generally in life, you might ask yourself, am I giving myself space, my sleeping, am I present, am I active, am I creative, and I'm
一首俳句后，他们都更有活力了，而且他们都举手说：“我想读我的俳句。”维克和其他研究人员发现的最后一个导致活力增加、从而带来目标的因素是吃得好。将这一点与其他四个因素结合起来，你就会得到一个维克喜欢称之为“SPACE”（空间）的首字母缩写。所以，如果你作为一名员工或在日常生活中精疲力竭，你可能会问自己：我是否在给自己“空间”？我在睡觉吗？我在当下吗？我活跃吗？我有创意吗？我有
eating well? And then over time, become a researcher of yourself and start asking yourself, are there certain letters there in space that are giving me even more energy? For me personally, I found that being creative was the number one thing I could do to have more energy and get more control, self-control of myself. So I love that. Now, the second part of that question is, if you have burned out like this person has, and now they are seeking a new chapter in their life, that's a perfect time to start repurposing your life, going back and really conducting that self-contemplation, that self-research, what we sometimes refer to as me search, and asking yourself, what are the things that are important in my life?
吃得好吗？然后随着时间的推移，成为你自己的研究员，开始问自己：SPACE中是否有某些字母正在给我带来更多的能量？就我个人而言，我发现发挥创造力是我能做的第一件事，能让我拥有更多能量，并对自我获得更多控制权、自控力。所以我很喜欢这一点。现在，这第二个问题的一部分是，如果你像这个人一样筋疲力竭，而现在他们正在寻找生活中的新篇章，那是开始重新规划生活、回顾并真正进行自我沉思、自我研究（有时我们称之为“自我搜寻”（me search））的绝佳时机，问问自己：我生活中重要的事情是什么？
You might ask yourself, who am I? What is my identity? And from that identity, I think I could start generating a purpose. And that can lead to then asking the question, are there certain skills that I need to generate, to become more effective in this next phase of my life? What I like about the initial, you know, doing research on yourself and noticing how sleep and exercise and creativity can affect you,
你可能会问自己：我是谁？我的身份是什么？从这个身份出发，我认为我可以开始产生一个目标。这可以引导我们进而提出这样一个问题：在我人生的下一个阶段，为了变得更有效率，我需要培养某些技能吗？我喜欢最初的（你知道的，对你自己做研究，并注意到睡眠、锻炼和创造力如何影响你）的原因是，
is that it doesn't require you to necessarily know all the answers to all the big questions. You can evaluate, you know, how well did I sleep the last three nights? You can evaluate how much exercise did I get the last three days. How well am I eating? And in some ways, there are practical things that we can do, even if we don't know the answers to the super big questions, what is my purpose, where is my meaning coming from, we can glean a lot of information from these mundane activities. Absolutely.
它不需要你一定知道所有宏大问题的答案。你可以评估（你知道的，过去三个晚上我睡得怎么样）。你可以评估过去三天我得到了多少锻炼。我吃得怎么样？在某种程度上，即使我们不知道那些超大问题的答案（我的目标是什么？我的意义从何而来？），也有我们可以做的实际事情，我们可以从这些平凡的活动中收集到大量信息。绝对的。
I mean, these are the things we've been told to do for what, decades and decades. And yet very often we don't do them. But if we are intrinsically motivated to do them and study them about ourselves, because we have this big, hairy, audacious purpose in our lives, then we start improving those behaviors. And we tend not to relapse as much. You know, if you try to work out more or try to change your diet or try to quit smoking or so many other behaviors, and I'm in public health, this is what I do professionally for the last 40 years, We know that the relapse rates, even after three to six months, can be 70 or 80 percent of people go back, rebound, almost like a rubber band, back to their old behaviors. But if they have this stronger intrinsic motivation to make a change, we don't see that relapse as much, not nearly as much.
我的意思是，这些都是我们几十年又几十年被告知要做的事情。然而，很多时候我们并没有做。但是，如果我们有内在的动力去做它们，并关于我们自己去研究它们，因为我们生活中有一个宏大、宏伟、大胆的目标，然后我们开始改善这些行为。而且我们往往不会复吸那么多。你知道的，如果你试图更多地锻炼，或试图改变你的饮食，或试图戒烟，或者许多其他行为——我是公共卫生出身，这是我过去40年的专业工作——我们知道，即使在三到六个月后，复发率也可能达到70%或80%，人们会像橡皮筋一样反弹回他们的旧行为。但是，如果他们有更强的内在动机去做出改变，我们就不会看到那么多的复发，几乎没有那么多。
So your life's purpose evolved after Julia passed away. a listener named Joanna faced a similar tragedy. She became a mom later in life, but nearly two years after giving birth, her daughter died in an accident. Here she is. I'm now a 53-year-old woman that doesn't have a purpose and doesn't care.
所以你的人生目标是在茱莉亚去世后演变而来的。一位名叫乔安娜（Joanna）的听众面临着类似的悲剧。她晚年成为了一名母亲，但在生下孩子近两年后，她的女儿在一次事故中去世了。她在这里。我现在是一个53岁的女性，没有目标，也不在乎。
My purpose was my little girl. My purpose was always just to be a workaholic. I am now days away from 54 years old. And life is impossible. I have a family, but they have their own lives. They have their own purposes, and I'm struggling to find a reason. Every day is literally a numbing battle. How would you suggest that I find a purpose?
我的目标是我小小的女孩。我的目标一直只是成为一个工作狂。我离54岁只有几天了。生活是不可能的。我有一个家庭，但他们有自己的生活。他们有自己的目标，我正在努力寻找一个理由。每一天字面意义上都是一场麻木的战斗。你觉得我该如何建议自己寻找一个目标？
I'm guessing this hits close to home to your own experience, Vic. As a parent who has been through the loss of a child, what guidance might you give Joanna, who is in the midst of unbearable grief? First of all, I'm so sorry for this person's loss. It is unbearable, and it continues. Gradually, it does get better. And if you can survive this, you can be an example to others who go through difficult times. That would be one of my messages. Now, I think being a mother, of a person whose lost a child is different than being a father. In fact, nobody goes through the same journey.
我猜这离你的亲身经历很近，维克。作为一个经历过丧子之痛的父母，对于正处于难以承受之痛中的乔安娜，你会给出什么指导？首先，我为这个人的损失感到非常抱歉。这是难以承受的，而且这种痛苦还在继续。渐渐地，它确实会变得更好。如果你能度过这个难关，你就能成为经历艰难时期之人的榜样。这将是我的信息之一。现在，我认为作为一个失去孩子的母亲与成为一个父亲是不同的。事实上，没有人经历相同的旅程。
No one is the same. I went through my own journey by reading Seneca and reading Rumi and many, many other philosophers and poets and writers. My wife went through a very different journey. And she decided to start volunteering in the children's hospital that was always taking of Julia. And she became a very active volunteer in the hospital. And that gave her life a great
没有人是相同的。我通过阅读塞内卡（Seneca）、鲁米（Rumi）以及许多许多其他哲学家、诗人和作家的书来度过我自己的旅程。我的妻子经历了非常不同的旅程。她决定开始在一直照顾茱莉亚的儿童医院做志愿服务。她成为了医院里非常活跃的志愿者。这赋予了她的生活很大
deal of meaning. I'm not a therapist. So I don't want to pretend that I can help an individual in a therapeutic way. All I can say is what's happened to my wife and I and other people that I have observed. And I think it's very important to find meaning through doing, through doing something, through being active, through giving in particular. I'll also say this, and it may sound trivial, but our dog has helped us a lot. We have a Jack Russell Terrier. His name is Uncle Lenny, and he keeps us active all the time. He's a very active dog, requires a lot of attention, and that helps.
部分的意义。我不是治疗师。所以我不装作我能以治疗的方式帮助个人。我只能说发生在我妻子和我身上以及我观察到的其他人的事情。我认为通过做某事、通过做事、通过保持活跃、特别是通过给予来寻找意义是非常重要的。我还要说这一点，这听起来可能微不足道，但我们的狗帮了我们很多。我们有一只杰克罗素梗犬（Jack Russell Terrier）。他的名字叫兰尼叔叔（Uncle Lenny），他一直让我们保持活跃。他是一只非常活跃的狗，需要很多关注，这有帮助。
So that's all I can say is what's happened to me personally. You mentioned a second ago, Vic, that it's how. helpful to focus on things that we can do as opposed to things that we can think. Can you talk about the distinction between those two approaches? Well, I think that doing, I think it was Gerta who once said in the beginning was the act. And getting out there in acting, getting out there and doing something like volunteering can be very helpful for people. And there's a lot of research that shows this as well. I know for me and personal life, I could sit and continue to read more and more and more philosophy and more and more
所以这就是我所能说的，发生在我个人身上的事。维克，你刚才提到，专注于我们可以做的事情，而不是我们可以思考的事情，是很有帮助的。你能谈谈这两种方法之间的区别吗？好吧，我认为“做”，我想是歌德（Goethe）曾经说过：“太初有为（In the beginning was the act）。”走出去行动，走出去做一些事情，比如做志愿者，对人们来说非常非常有帮助。有很多研究也表明了这一点。我知道对于我和我的个人生活来说，我可以坐着继续阅读越来越多、越来越多的哲学，越来越多、越来越多的
Seneca and more Victor Frankel, et cetera. And all of that was helpful for my mindset, but ultimately I had to go into the classroom and teach and stop a second as I was teaching or just before as everybody's just walking into the classroom and sitting down and looking at every one of my students and taking a breath and saying, all of you are my daughters right now. Just to myself. I don't say it to anybody in the classroom. I just think that. And then it gives me this profound energy for teaching. And I think somehow trying to create that approach to your doing can be very helpful.
塞内卡和维克多·弗兰克尔（Viktor Frankl）等。所有这一切对我的心态都有帮助，但最终我不得不走进教室教书，并在我教书时停顿一秒钟，或者在每个人走进教室坐下并看着我的每一个学生并深呼吸之前，对自己说：“你们现在都是我的女儿。”仅仅在心里对自己说。我没有对教室里的任何人说。我只是这么想。然后这给了我深厚的教学能量。而且我认为某种程度上试图为你所做的事情创造这种方法会非常有帮助。
This is your questions answered, our segment in which we bring researchers back to answer listener questions. After the break, Vic will answer questions on how the question. to support others in finding their own meaning in life and why it's never too late to start pursuing your values. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When was the last time you decided to do
这是你的问题解答，这是我们的板块，我们带回研究人员来回答听众的问题。休息后，维克将回答关于如何支持他人寻找他们自己的生命意义以及为什么开始追求你的价值永远不会太晚的问题。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你上一次决定做
something novel, and it ended up a failure. Maybe it was something as simple as picking up a new hobby and not having the knack for it, or perhaps you decided to read a book a month, but got to the end of the year and only finished one. These kinds of experiences may have you asking yourself if you're strong enough, brave enough, smart enough. At the University of Michigan, Victor Strecker studies the science of purpose and the ways we can all find more meaning in our lives. Vic, in our first conversation, you described a powerful experience you had after your daughter died. You were kayaking by yourself early one morning when you heard her voice telling you that it was time to get over your ego and start thinking about things bigger than yourself.
某件新鲜事是什么时候，而它却以失败告终？也许这就像培养一项新爱好却发现自己没有天赋一样简单，或者也许你决定一个月读一本书，但到了年底却只读完了一本。这类经历可能会让你问自己：你是否足够坚强、足够勇敢、足够聪明？在密歇根大学，维克托·斯特雷克研究目标的科学，以及我们所有人都能在生活中找到更多意义的方法。维克，在我们的第一次对话中，你描述了女儿去世后你经历的一次深刻体验。那天清晨，你独自一人在划皮划艇，听到她的声音告诉你，是时候放下你的自我，开始思考比你自己更宏大的事情了。
We had a listener named Gretchen, write in with a question about the relationship between purpose and ego. Gretchen writes, as I've looked inward and as I've been seeking my own sense of purpose, and as I've asked for help and listen to other stories, I keep hearing that I have to get over myself. I'm inspired to be argumentative here because getting over myself only feels like another form of shaming and not helpful. Gretchen wants to know if she's misunderstanding your advice, Vic. What would you say to her? Well, first of all, thank you, Gretchen, for that wonderful feedback, because when I was saying, you need to get over yourself, and I think it was actually
有一位名叫格雷琴（Gretchen）的听众写信给我们，提出了一个关于目标与自我（ego）之间关系的问题。格雷琴写道：当我向内看并一直在寻找我自己的目标感时，当我寻求帮助并倾听其他人的故事时，我不断听到我必须“放下自我（get over myself）”。我在这里被激起了一种争论的心态，因为“放下自我”感觉只是另一种形式的羞耻感，并没有帮助。格雷琴想知道她是否误解了你的建议，维克。你会对她说些什么？好吧，首先，谢谢你，格雷琴，提供那条美妙的反馈，因为当我当时说“你需要放下自我”时，我想实际上是
Julia, my daughter, telling me I needed to get over myself. I try to emphasize that it wasn't like, you need to get over this. That was the last thing that I wanted to say. What I was trying to say is, I need to get over my own ego. I need to
茱莉亚，我的女儿，告诉我需要放下自我。我试图强调它不是那种：“你需要放下这个。”那是我最不想说的话。我试图说的是：我需要放下我自己的自我（ego）。我需要
transcend my ego, as opposed to continually ruminate within your own ego, within your own castle wall. Somehow, above that castle wall. Open that draw bridge. Leave the castle. Be exposed to other people. Be exposed to failure. Be exposed to the potential for not being perfect when you're out there. Maybe also, I'll never forget a day or two after our daughter passed away. I was walking with a couple of my friends.
超越我的自我（ego），而不是不断地在你自己的自我（ego）内、在你自己的城堡墙内反刍。某种程度上，超越那堵城堡墙。打开那座吊桥。离开城堡。暴露于其他人。暴露于失败。在走出去时暴露于不完美的可能性中。也许还有，我永远不会忘记女儿去世一两天后的那一天。我和几个朋友一起散步。
they're asking what I needed and I said the thing I need is for you to still be my friend when I'm probably not the most attractive person to be a friend with I really would hope that they would still be a friend so no I don't think it's about somehow getting over yourself and turning around and you know just you know battening the hatches and and and you're you're going out there going, I'm now a stronger person, darn it. It is more about transcending that castle wall that you're in. I think that's what I was trying to convey. And I apologize if I didn't convey it in that way, because I certainly didn't mean
他们问我需要什么，我说我需要的是：当我可能不是一个做朋友的最好看的人时，你们依然是我的朋友。我真的希望他们依然是我的朋友。所以，不，我认为这无关乎某种程度上放下自我，然后转身（你知道的，只是拉紧舱门），然后你走出去说：“我现在是一个更坚强的人了，该死的。”它更多的是关于超越你所处的城堡墙。我想这就是我试图传达的。如果我没有以那种方式传达，我深表歉意，因为我当然不是那个意思
you need to get over yourself. That would certainly be blaming the victim, I think. I'm curious to hear your thoughts on how shame and other negative emotions can complicate our pursuit of purpose. Some listeners hear about the power of purpose, and they want a sense of purpose, but they don't have it. And now this becomes another source of shame and unhappiness. Did you ever go through anything like this, Vic? It's a wonderful question. I did not go through any sense of shame in searching for my purpose or trying to find my purpose, but I have run into people who have. I'll never forget, it's maybe five years after
你需要放下自我。我想那肯定是在责备受害者。我很好奇听到你对羞耻感和其他负面情绪如何使我们对目标的追求变得复杂的看法。一些听众听到了目标的力量，他们想要一种目标感，但他们没有。现在这成了羞耻感和不快乐的另一个来源。维克，你有没有经历过这样的事情？这是一个绝妙的问题。在寻找我的目标或试图寻找我的目标时，我没有经历任何羞耻感，但我确实遇到过有这种感觉的人。我永远不会忘记，那大约是在五年后
I wrote my book, Life on Purpose. I was invited to give a keynote to a national OB-GYN conference. So these are obstetricians and gynecologists, many of whom were women. And after my keynote, I ran a workshop about finding purpose. And so many of these people came in from the keynote address, and most of them were women and they said, you just freaked me out, Vic. I said, how did I freak out? Well, now this is one more thing I need to do
我写过一本书叫《有目的的生活》。我应邀在一个全国性的妇产科大会上做主旨演讲。与会者都是产科和妇科医生，其中很多是女性。演讲结束后，我举办了一个关于寻找人生意义的研讨会。许多人都是听完主旨演讲直接过来的，其中大部分是女性，她们对我说：“维克，你刚才把我吓坏了。”我问：“我怎么把你吓坏了？”她们说：“现在这成了我又一件必须要做的事，
and I need to be really good at. And of course we know very often that women sometimes feel, you know, a sense that they need to be perfect and do better. And there's so many reasons for this, sexist reasons for this that I try to understand. But it just came out so strongly from these women.
而且我必须把它做得非常好。”当然，我们知道很多时候女性有时会觉得，你知道的，她们需要追求完美，表现得更好。这背后的原因有很多，包括我一直试图理解的性别偏见原因。但这些女性表达出的这种压力实在是太强烈了。
And here I'm thinking these are incredibly successful people, incredibly successful women, professionals who have accomplished everything they strive for in their lives. And here they are. I've just given them one more thing to worry about. That's unfortunate. And I don't mean to be doing that. We had another question related to shame around one's purpose. A listener named Erica wrote in with a question about how to cope with the purpose that you don't choose, but which is thrust upon you. Erica became a long-term caregiver for a few of her family members at a very young age.
而当时我在想，这些人可是极其成功的人士，极其成功的职业女性，她们已经实现了生活中奋斗追求的一切。然而现在呢，我却给她们平添了一件需要操心的事。这太不幸了。我并非有意如此。我们收到了另一个与围绕人生意义的羞耻感相关的问题。一位名叫埃里卡的听众发来提问，询问如何应对那些并非自己选择、而是强加给自己的使命。埃里卡在很年轻的时候就成了家里几位成员的长期照顾者。
Here's her question. I know intrinsically that this is valuable, that this is meaningful, that this is important. And so I can sound like a horrible, grumpy, selfish person saying, I don't. want this purpose, but I would really like to connect with it in a big way and feel comfortable about it and the sacrifices that I have to make in order for this purpose to come to fruition. How do you change your relationship to a purpose that you didn't necessarily pick for yourself, Vic? So Erica brings up such an important point, and thank you, Erica, for the question.
她的问题是这样的：我从内心深处知道这是有价值的、有意义的、重要的。所以当我说“我其实不想要这个使命”时，我听起来可能像个可怕、暴躁、自私的人，但我真的很想深刻地与它建立联系，并对它以及为了让这个使命实现而必须做出的牺牲感到坦然。维克，你如何改变自己与一个并非自己主动选择的使命的关系呢？埃里卡提出了一个非常重要的问题，谢谢埃里卡提出这个问题。
I just, I couldn't help. stopping when you said horrible grumpy selfish really so you're a caregiver of multiple people in your family you were thrust into that role um and then suddenly you are now the person that people turn to they need you it's essential they rely on you it's very hard being a caregiver there is some research that shows that many caregivers don't actually label themselves as a caregiver they just experience the stress. They just experience the difficulties, the noise, the loss of income, the many, many things they have to go through by taking care of a person or people.
我刚刚……我忍不住在你说到“可怕、暴躁、自私”时停了下来。真的吗？所以你是家中多个人的照顾者，你被硬生生地推入了那个角色；然后突然之间，你成了人们依赖的人，他们需要你，你是不可或缺的，他们指望你。做照顾者非常艰难。有一些研究表明，许多照顾者实际上并没有给自己贴上“照顾者”的标签，他们只是在经历压力。他们只是在经历困难、嘈杂、收入损失，以及为了照顾一个人或多个人而不得不经历的许许多多事情。
But they never label themselves as a caregiver. And it turns out to be a very helpful thing. To label yourself, I am a caregiver. Suddenly that's saying, I have a purpose in my life. We had another question related to shame and purpose. Listener, Cheryl, wrote in with this question, when someone loses their job or has a deep disappointment that jars their purpose, such as an agent saying no to their book over and over,
但他们从未称自己为照顾者。事实证明，给自己贴上标签——“我是一名照顾者”——是非常有帮助的。突然之间，这就意味着：我的生命是有意义的。我们收到了另一个与羞耻感和人生意义相关的问题。听众谢丽尔发来这样一个问题：当一个人失业，或者遭遇了严重打击其人生意义的挫折时，比如代理人一次次拒绝他们的书稿，
or many knows to job prospects after getting fired or laid off, these nos tend to have people question themselves and their purpose and even doubt themselves. They ask themselves if they're doing the right thing. So I'm wondering if you have any strategies for helping people get back on track. So, Vic, it can be difficult to feel like you're on the right, track when you keep having doors slammed in your face. What's your advice for Cheryl? Wow, Cheryl, great question. Love the question. So I'd like to tell my students to be willing to
或者在被解雇或裁员后，求职申请遭到一次次拒绝，这些拒绝往往会让人开始质疑自己、质疑自己的人生意义，甚至对自己产生怀疑。他们会问自己到底是不是在做正确的事。所以我想知道，你有什么策略可以帮助这些人重回正轨吗？维克，当你不断遭到闭门羹时，很难觉得自己正走在正确的轨道上。你对谢丽尔有什么建议？哇，谢丽尔，好问题。我很喜欢这个问题。所以我想告诉我的学生，要甘于
fail, double the number of failures. There's a star tennis player named is Emma Navarro, and she's one of the top 10 tennis players in the world, female tennis players. And her father, Ben Navarro, lives in Charleston and he teaches a course on intentionality and we were talking the other day and he said in my class I have my students go out and purposely fail in something and then write about it right about that failure right about the emotions right about the experience and right about what you're going to do now so this is what you know obviously really at the heart of what I believe Carol Dweck's growth mindset is all about. Are you willing to fail? And then when you have a failure, how do you interpret that failure? And I think it's very important that you continue being willing
失败，将失败的次数翻倍。有一位明星网球运动员叫埃玛·纳瓦罗，她是世界顶尖的10天网球运动员之一，女性网球运动员。她的父亲本·纳瓦罗住在查尔斯顿，他教一门关于专注力的课程。我们前几天聊天时，他说：“在我的课上，我让学生们走出去，故意在某件事上失败，然后把这次失败写下来，写下这种失败，写下当时的 emociones，写下这段经历，再写下你接下来打算怎么做。”所以，这正是卡罗尔·德韦克的成长型思维的核心所在。你愿意失败吗？而当你遭遇失败时，你如何解读这次失败？我认为非常重要的一点是，你必须继续保持
to try something and maybe fail in it. It is important. At the same time, if you just keep beating your head against the wall continually doing the same thing, of course, that's not good either. So it's a tricky tricky answer to provide for people. There's a narrative in many parts of the world that you need to have an impressive job, a picture perfect family, a nice house, in order to have made it. But it seems like your research disproves this idea and shows that many forms of purpose can be beneficial. Can you talk a bit about the conversations you have with people doing so-called ordinary jobs
去尝试某事并可能会经历失败的意愿。这很重要。与此同时，如果你只是不断地拿头撞墙，一而再再而三地做同一件事，那当然也是不行的。所以这是一个很难回答的问题。世界许多地方都有一种说法：你必须拥有一份令人印象深刻的工作、一个完美的家庭、一座漂亮的房子，才算获得了成功。但看起来你的研究推翻了这种观点，并表明各种形式的人生意义都可以是有益的。你能聊聊你与那些从事所谓普通工作的人进行的对话吗？
and how many of them report having a sense of deep purpose? You know, the classic case of having a purpose in your work, no matter what you're doing, goes back to 1962 when John F. Kennedy was touring NASA and he walked up to a maintenance work or a custodian and said, hi, I'm, you know, John F. Kennedy, what do you do? And he said, well, Mr. President, I'm helping put a man on the moon. I've heard about so many people who have fairly, what? one might consider mundane jobs, and they find great purpose in those jobs. I remember we had a septic tank that needed emptying out in the front of our house, and I remember talking to the manager there and asking him about his job, said, why do you do this? Because, you know, it's a pretty smelly job, obviously. It's a very smelly job, actually.
他们中有多少人表示自己有着深刻的人生意义感？你知道，无论你做什么工作，在工作中找到人生意义的经典案例可以追溯到1962年。当时约翰·F·肯尼迪正在视察NASA，他走到一个维修工或清洁工面前说：“嗨，我是约翰·F·肯尼迪，你是做什么的？”那个人说：“哦，总统先生，我正在协助把人类送上月球。”我听说过太多人，他们从事的或许是人们可能认为很平凡的工作，但他们在这些工作找到了伟大的意义。我记得我们家门前有一个化粪池需要清理，我记得跟那里的经理交谈，问起他的工作，问他为什么要做这个？因为，你知道的，这显然是一份气味相当难闻的工作。事实上，这确实是一份气味非常难闻的工作。
And he looked at me like I was kind of crazy, and he said, well, for the money. And I said, do you realize that this is one of the most important things that one could ever do in public health? Through the history of humankind, taking the poop out of the water system is one of the most important things anyone has ever done for the public salt. And that's what you do. In a way, you are a public health worker. And his eyes kind of lit up. He literally then said, can I give you my card? And I said, well, of course.
他看着我，就像看着一个疯子一样，然后说：“为了钱啊。”我说：“你难道不知道这是公共卫生领域最重要的事情之一吗？在人类历史中，把排泄物从供水系统中清理出去，是人类为公共健康所做过的最重要的事之一。而这就是你的工作。从某种意义上说，你是一名公共卫生工作者。”他的眼睛一下子亮了。他甚至字面意义上地问我：“我能给你一张我的名片吗？”我说：“当然可以。”
And it suddenly, it almost was like some light clicked in him. I don't know whether that will stay. I don't know whether it's changed his life. But at least at that point, he may have viewed his job in a different way. One of the jobs that's been considered the least purposeful and the least paying is parking attendant. And I started talking about that once in a group. And somebody came up afterwards and told me a story about their parking attendant because they always had to park in the same place. And this parking attendant literally had a small ruler and he would go around to all the cars and all the tires and measure the tire tread.
这突然之间，几乎就像他心里有什么灯被点亮了一样。我不知道这会不会持久。我不知道这是否改变了他的人生。但至少在那个时刻，他可能以一种不同的方式看待自己的工作。被认为最没有意义、薪水最低的工作之一就是停车管理员。我有一次在一个群体里谈到这个。随后有一个人走过来，跟我讲了一个关于他们的停车管理员的故事，因为他们总是必须把车停在同一个地方。这个停车管理员居然随身带着一把小尺子，他会走到所有的汽车和轮胎旁，测量轮胎的花纹深度。
And then when the car left, the parking attendant would say, if you had low tire tread, say, by the way, maybe you need some new tires. Did you notice you have very low tire tread? that's a very purposeful person. Wow. What I'm taking away from this, Vic, is that, you know, it is the case that sometimes we can go in search of great purpose. There might be activities that we are not doing right now that could provide us with a great sense of purpose.
然后等车开走后，停车管理员会对车主说，如果轮胎花纹很浅的话：“顺便说一句，你可能需要换新轮胎了。你注意到你的轮胎花纹已经非常浅了吗？”这是一个非常有意义的人。哇。维克，我从中领悟到的是，有时候我们的确可以去寻找伟大的意义。有些我们现在没有在做的事情，可能会赋予我们强烈的意义感。
But what you're pointing out is that many of the activities that we are doing now, we are already doing, we can locate purpose within those activities. You know, how many times have you gone up to a cashier, you're checking out, right? And that cashier looks as if they can't wait. They're looking at their watch. They simply can't wait for their shift to end. And they're counting the minutes. And there are other people go, hi, how are you doing? How is your day? Did you get everything that you needed? There's night and day. Now, which employee do you think becomes happier, not just is happy, but becomes happy as a result of those interactions that they have with people? I think it's pretty clear. So I do think that to some extent you can choose, to another extent, sometimes you run into a cashier and they're just, they're grumpy and they're not looking at you. And you may interpret that as a person being a mean person, not a good person, or it could well be that they just had an awful day or has a sick child in the hospital or is going through a divorce or just, you know,
但你指出的是，许多我们现在正在做的事情，我们已经身处其中，我们可以在这些活动中找到意义。你知道，你有多频繁地走到收银台前结账？而那个收银员看起来好像一刻也等不及了。他们看着手表，简直恨不得自己的班次赶紧结束。他们在倒计时。而另一些人则会说：“嗨，你好吗？今天过得怎么样？你买齐你需要的所有东西了吗？”这简直有着天壤之别。现在，你认为哪位员工会变得更快乐？不仅仅是“感到快乐”，而是通过与人们的这些互动最终变得快乐？我想这相当明显。所以我确实认为，在某种程度上你可以做出选择；但在另一方面，有时候你遇到一个收银员，他们就是脾气暴躁，不愿看你一眼。你可能会把这解读为这个人刻薄、不是个好人；但也有可能，他们只是刚经历了糟糕的一天，或者有个生病的孩子在医院，或者正在经历离婚，或者只是，你知道的，
their husband or wife or spouse just lost their job. There are many things that people are going through. So making attributions about why a person is acting in a certain way, I think is not a good thing to do. On the other hand, trying to extend yourself to another person in a way that may improve, I can't tell you how many people if they are just looking kind of glazed or, grumpy, I might ask how their day is going. And very often, they'll turn to me and say, well, here's how it's going. And then you have a conversation and you leave much more, both of you leave much more satisfied. We had a few parents write in about centering their life
他们的丈夫、妻子或伴侣刚刚失业。人们正在经历的事情有很多。因此，对一个人为什么会有某种行为妄加揣测，我认为并不是一件好事。另一方面，试着以一种可能会改善对方状态的方式去关怀他人——我简直无法告诉你，当别人看起来眼神呆滞或暴躁时，有多少次我会主动问他们今天过得怎么样。很多时候，他们会转过身对我说：“好吧，情况是这样的。”然后你们就聊了起来，结果你们俩都带着极大的满足感离开。我们收到了一些父母的来信，他们把自己的生活
purpose around their children's well-being and feeling apprehension about what will happen once their kids grow up. A listener named Nita sent us a question on this topic. I'm a physician, in my mid-50s and suddenly finding myself at a loss to find the right purpose to go on when you're younger and you're trying to build your career, make sure you have the right amount in your nest egg, raising children, making sure that they turn into productive citizens. All of that might sound hard, but you have this in-built purpose and you don't have to make a new purpose on a daily basis to feel that you're not just merely surviving but you're actually thriving and suddenly I found myself at that point where my children are turning into
重心放在孩子的幸福上，并对孩子们长大后会发生什么感到焦虑。一位名叫尼塔的听众就这个话题向我们发问。我是一名医生，五十多岁，突然发现自己不知该如何找到合适的人生意义继续前行。当你年轻的时候，你努力建立事业，确保你的退休储蓄充足，抚养孩子，确保他们成为对社会有用的人。这一切听起来可能很难，但你有着这种内置的人生意义，你不需要每天都创造一个新的意义，来让自己觉得你不仅是在勉强生存，而是在真正地蓬勃发展。而突然之间，我发现自己来到了这样一个人生节点：我的孩子们正在变成
productive citizens they don't need me anymore they're in their mid-20s I am doing well in my career and yet find myself lacking in something so deep-seated that it's hard to express. How does one find a new purpose? How does one find something new, something meaningful, something that's beyond oneself? So we had other parents write in to express similar anxieties, Vic. what would you recommend to folks like Nita? First of all, the micro issue itself of being an empty nester. So this happens very often when parents have devoted so much of their attention,
对社会有用的人，他们不再需要我了，他们已经二十多岁了；我的事业也进展顺利，然而我却发现自己内心深处有一种难以言表的东西在缺失。一个人如何找到新的人生意义？一个人如何找到新鲜的、有意义的、超越自我的东西？所以我们收到了其他父母发来的信件，表达了类似的焦虑，维克。你会向像尼塔这样的人推荐什么？首先，是空巢老人这个微观问题本身。这种情况经常发生，当父母把太多的注意力、
their lives to their children, and suddenly their children are gone. You can certainly help a person after they have left the home and support them through your own advice, through financial assistance, through many things. through encouragement, through being a sage that they turn to, a person that they turn to for advice. All of those things are certainly helpful. But also, it may well be a time for you to become a really great model for your children in how you actually live this next chapter of your life. For example, maybe if there are other things they can get engaged in, it could be a
把他们的人生都倾注在孩子身上，而突然之间孩子离开了。当然，在孩子离开家之后，你仍然可以通过你自己的建议、经济上的支持、通过方方面面的事情来帮助他们。通过鼓励，通过成为他们遇到难事时可以求教的智者、可以咨询的人。所有这些当然都很有帮助。但同时，这也可能是一个绝佳的时机，让你成为孩子们如何度过人生下一篇章的真正伟大的榜样。例如，也许还有其他他们可以参与的事情，比如
hobby. You can be very purposeful within a hobby. I know, for example, I work in a medical school, so I know a lot of physicians who in retirement or as they became anthony nesters took up things like woodworking or painting or other hobbies. And they became enamored with those and really got into it. They're happy. Or maybe it's pickleball. Whatever it is. What you're doing then is setting example for your children that it's not all about having children. It's not all about them. It is about doing something that's fulfilling and flourishing in your, that you can produce, you can flourish in your own life without the necessity of children. And what that makes you, I think, is a better parent. You pointed out to me that when you returned to your classroom
爱好。你完全可以在爱好中找到深刻的意义。我知道，比如我在医学院工作，所以我认识很多医生，他们在退休或成为空巢老人后，开始接触木工、绘画或其他爱好。他们对这些深深着迷，真正投入其中。他们很快乐。或者也许是匹克球。不管是什么。你所做的是在为你的孩子树立一个榜样：生活并不全是为了生养孩子，生活不完全是围着他们转。而是去做一些充实且能让自己蓬勃发展的事，在没有孩子的情况下，你也能在自己的生活中绽放光彩。而我认为，这会让你成为一个更好的父母。你曾向我指出，当朱莉去世后你重返课堂时，
after Julia passed away, you started to look at all of your students as, as your daughter, as your children. And in some ways, that does offer a possibility, does it not? If you're an empty nester, yes, you know, maybe your children don't need your help anymore. Maybe they're well settled and they're becoming productive citizens and that's wonderful. But surely there are other children who might need your help. Precisely. I couldn't agree more.
你开始把所有的学生都看作是你的女儿、你的孩子。从某种意义上说，这确实提供了一种可能性，不是吗？如果你是一位空巢老人，是的，也许你的孩子们不再需要你的帮助了。也许他们已经安居乐业，正在成为对社会有用的人，这很棒。但肯定还有其他孩子可能需要你的帮助。确切地说。我完全赞同。
When you start looking outside of your immediate family and start asking, what could I do for my friends? What could I do for my neighbors? What could I do for my community? What could I do for my country? What could I do for people in other countries? That to me is the epitome of purpose and a transcending purpose. And there's probably nothing greater that you could teach your children than this act of self-transcendence.
当你开始把目光投向直系亲属之外，开始问：我能为我的朋友做些什么？我能为我的邻居做些什么？我能为我的社区做些什么？我能为我的国家做些什么？我能为其他国家的人做些什么？对我和来说，这就是人生意义的巅峰，是一种超越自我的意义。除了这种超越自我的行为，你可能再也教不了你的孩子更伟大的东西了。
And moving beyond the immediate family, obviously they've given. given you a lot, and you've given them a lot. But what do you really give them now? You give them the example of yourself. This is your questions answered, our segment in which we bring researchers back to answer listener questions. When we come back, we'll talk about whether there's a way to measure our success at pursuing our purpose. Plus, how to encourage loved ones to find more meaning in their lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
超越小家庭的范畴，显然他们付出了很多，你也付出了很多。但你现在真正能给他们什么呢？你给他们的是你自己的榜样。这里是“你的问题已解答”，这是我们邀请研究人员回归解答听众提问的环节。稍后回来，我们将探讨是否有办法衡量我们在追求人生意义方面的成功。此外，还要探讨如何鼓励所爱之人从生活中寻找更多意义。您正在收听的是《隐藏的脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In a world that is constantly in flux, it can be difficult to know what to prioritize. Family, work, your own well-being? At the University of Michigan, Victor Strecker researchers how to find direction in life. His work focuses on the science of purpose and the ways we can all benefit from making our lives more meaningful. Vic, your previous conversation with us clearly struck a chord with listeners. We received a flood of questions and comments from people who are interested in engaging deeply with the ideas
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在一个瞬息万变的世界里，很难知道什么才是优先事项。家庭、工作、还是你自己的身心健康？在密歇根大学，维克托·斯特雷克研究如何在生活中找到方向。他的工作聚焦于目的论科学，以及我们所有人如何通过让生活更有意义而获益。维克，你之前的对话显然在听众中引起了强烈共鸣。我们收到了大量的问题和评论，来自那些对深入探讨我们讨论过的理念
as we discussed. I'm curious to hear whether you also received a number of responses to that episode and whether they've impacted how you think about your work in research? I've received a huge number, hundreds, many hundreds of responses from people through email, through LinkedIn, through many, many ways. And it seems to have really touched a chord. And from that, I am grateful because I think this has. this is a very important area of people's lives now.
感兴趣的人们。我很想听听，你是否也收到了大量针对那一集的反馈，它们是否影响了你对研究工作的思考？我收到了海量的反馈，数百条、好几百条来自人们的回复，通过电子邮件、通过领英、通过各种各样的方式。这似乎真的触动了人们的心弦。对此我心怀感激，因为我认为这是一个……这已经是人们生活中非常重要的一个领域。
And it's not just since COVID. I think you could go back 2400 years to Aristotle, who asked these same questions of what makes us happy. And he basically said having a purpose and direction is what makes us happy. So many of the questions we received from listeners had to do with how to identify your purpose in life, whether that is during a life transition or after a loss of some kind. but a listener named Victoria sent us a question about the opposite problem, having too many purposes in life.
而且不仅是在新冠疫情之后。我想你可以追溯到2400年前的亚里士多德，他也曾提出过同样的关于什么让我们快乐的问题。他基本上说过，拥有目的和方向就是让我们快乐的原因。我们从听众那里收到的许多问题，都与如何在生活中确定自己的人生意义有关，无论是在人生转型期还是在经历某种失去之后。但有一位名叫维多利亚的听众给我们发来了一个关于相反问题的问题：生活中拥有太多的人生目标。
And I have been a student of purpose since I graduated from college, and I have felt like I have had multiple purposes for so long, but I have had the hardest time activating them and really nurturing them to be fulfilled to their highest level. What is your thought or suggestion for people who may be like me and just have all of these multiple purposes and ideas and passions and heartfelt things that they want to see in the world, but just make struggle with not spreading themselves through then trying to do it all? So Victoria seems fortunate in that she's almost overflowing with purpose, Vic, but she finds a challenging to know how to prioritize. her passions and concentrate on one or two things. What guidance would you offer her? I can relate to Victoria, by the way, because I have lots of purposes in different domains. I certainly have community purposes. I have family purposes. My wife and I have strong purpose
自从大学毕业以来，我一直是一个研究人生意义的学生，很长一段时间以来，我感觉自己拥有多重人生目标，但我发现最难的事情是激活它们，并真正地培育它们，让它们发挥到极致。对于像我这样拥有所有这些多重目标、想法、激情以及想要在这个世界上实现的心愿，却又苦于无法面面俱到而将自己精力分散的人，你有什么想法或建议吗？维多利亚似乎很幸运，因为她的人生意义几乎要溢出来了，维克，但她发现很难知道如何去优先处理
in our relationship together. We have purpose with our children and certainly strong purpose and work. So I can relate. And I'm always thinking, boy, how do you balance these purposes? I can talk about getting more energy and vitality so that you can develop, you know, actually be more aligned with all of those purposes. But can having so many different domains of purpose burn you out? I would think so. Yes, I think it can be. So you do need to give yourself some downtime, some relaxation time, maybe even some purposeless time. As one of my mentors, Jim Lair, has told me many times that energy is the most important aspect that we can have in our lives. Thinking about not health, but thinking about energy. Do I have vitality? Do I have energy? What gives me more energy every single day?
她的激情并专注于一两件事。你会给她什么指导呢？顺便说一句，我能对维多利亚感同身受，因为我在不同的领域有很多目标。我当然有社区层面的目标。我有家庭层面的目标。我和妻子在我们的伴侣关系中有强烈的目标感。我们在孩子身上有目标，在工作中当然也有强烈的目标。所以我能感同身受。我总是在想，天哪，你该如何平衡这些目标呢？我可以谈谈如何获得更多的精力和活力，以便你能够发展……你知道，实际上与所有这些目标更加契合。但拥有如此多不同领域的人生目标会让你精疲力竭吗？我想会的。是的，我认为会的。所以你确实需要给自己一些停工时间、放松时间，甚至是一些毫无目的的时间。正如我的导师之一吉姆·莱尔曾多次对我说的那样，精力是我们生活中最重要的方面。考虑的不是健康，而是精力。我有活力吗？我有精力吗？什么每天都能给我带来更多的精力？
So we could go all the way back then to these space criteria of sleep, presence, activity, creativity, and eating, so that you can live and be purposeful in multiple domains. At the same time, you may need to learn to say no as well. A listener named Julie asked about how we can know if we are achieving our purpose. My question is, how do we measure if we're achieving our purpose? Sometimes I feel like, God, there's so much that I can't fix. Maybe it's more about agency, but, yeah, I sometimes feel like, am I doing enough? And do I need to have self-enhancing goals in order to create that pathway so I can use my agency?
所以我们最后可以追溯到睡眠、当下、活动、创造力和饮食这几个基本标准，这样你才能在多个领域生活并活出意义。与此同时，你可能也需要学会拒绝。一位名叫朱莉的听众询问我们如何才能知道自己是否正在实现人生意义。我的问题是，我们如何衡量我们是否在实现自己的人生意义？有时候我觉得，天哪，有太多事情是我无法解决的。也许这更多关乎能动性，但是，是的，有时我感觉：我做得够了吗？为了创造通往能够运用我的能动性的道路，我需要设定自我提升的目标吗？
Wondering what you think, Vic, is there a way to measure our success at fulfilling our purpose? Wonderful question from Julie. I think I'm going to separate the word goal from the word purpose. So a goal is achievable. I mean, almost by nature, a goal typically is something that there is a possibility of achieving. Now, goals are very close to purpose, but purpose doesn't necessarily need to be achievable. It needs to be aspirational. So I may aspire to teaching every one of my students as if they're my own daughter.
不知道你是怎么想的，维克，有没有办法衡量我们实现人生意义的成功程度？朱莉提出了一个绝佳的问题。我想把“目标”这个词与“人生意义”这个词区分开来。所以，目标是可实现的。我的意思是，几乎从本质上讲，目标通常是某种存在实现可能性的东西。现在，目标与人生意义非常接近，但人生意义不一定需要是可实现的。它需要是追求性的。所以我可能追求像对待自己的女儿一样去教导我的每一个学生。
That's probably not achievable. But it is aspirational. In other words, I go into the class with the mindset or into my office hours with the mindset that I am going to try to do that. That becomes a purpose, a direction, an intention of mine. But not necessarily a goal that's achievable. So the two are different. And I have to accept the fact that the purposes I have in my life are not going to necessarily be met.
这可能无法实现。但它是一个追求。换句话说，我带着这种心态走进课堂，或者带着这种心态进入我的答疑时间，即我将努力去做到这一点。这成了一种人生意义、一种方向、一种我的意图。但这不一定是一个可以实现的目标。所以这两者是不同的。我必须接受这样一个事实：我生命中的那些意义，不一定非得全部达成。
You spend a lot of time, Vic, in your professional life, teaching people how to find and fulfill their purpose. We had listeners ask how they can do the same for other people in their lives. An elementary school, art teacher named Erin, sent us this question. We're amidst a mental health crisis, which includes our youth. And if we as adults struggle to thrive without purpose, how do we expect our children to thrive? So you work with young people at the college level, Vic. Erin works with children much younger than that. At what age do you think it's appropriate to introduce themes of purpose to kids?
维克，你在职业生涯中花了很多时间教导人们如何寻找和实现他们的人生意义。有听众询问他们如何为生活中的其他人做到这一点。一位名叫艾琳的小学美术老师给我们发了这样一个问题：我们正处于一场心理健康危机之中，其中也包括我们的年轻人。如果我们这些成年人在没有人生意义的情况下都难以蓬勃发展，我们又怎么能期望我们的孩子们蓬勃发展呢？维克，你在大学层面与年轻人共事。艾琳接触的则是更小的孩子。你认为在什么年龄引入人生意义的主题给孩子们是合适的？
And how can you encourage kids to begin to find their own purpose? Well, first of all, there is another episode that you did with a person named Tony Burrow, Anthony Burrow at Cornell. And Tony Burrough is a developmental psychologist. So he focuses a lot on that developmental process, and he's one of the world's experts on purpose. So first of all, I'd suggest you go to that episode and listen because it's such a powerful episode. But what I would suggest, and I have worked with kids different times, different situations. And I think the idea of starting with what matters most, just like with adults. So if you ask a child, what matters most right now?
你又该如何鼓励孩子们开始寻找他们自己的人生意义呢？首先，你在另一期节目中采访过一个人，他就是康奈尔大学的托尼·伯勒（安东尼·伯勒）。托尼·伯勒是一位发展心理学家。所以他非常关注那个发展过程，他是世界顶尖的人生意义专家之一。所以首先，我建议你去听听那一期节目，因为那是一期非常有力量的节目。但我会建议——我曾在不同时间、不同情况下与孩子们共事过。我认为可以从最重要的事情开始，这与成年人是一样的。所以如果你问一个孩子：现在什么最重要？
And they may go climate change matters most. There are different things that may matter most. I'll give you one example. My seven-year-old grandson saw a documentary about shrimp and the unsafe harvesting of shrimp. Well, he was so alarmed by this that he decided to put together a group of people in his hometown. They made signs, and the sign said things like save the shrimp, and suddenly the ex-mayor became involved in this, and they started parading along the side of the street with these Save the shrimp placards, and this became a purpose of his, and he's seven years old.
他们的回答可能是气候变化最重要。会有各种各样他们认为最重要的事情。我给你举个例子。我七岁的孙子看了一部关于虾以及不安全捕虾方式的纪录片。结果他对此感到非常震惊，以至于他决定在他所在的家乡组织一群人。他们制作了标语，标语上写着诸如“拯救虾”之类的话，突然之间前市长也参与了进来，他们开始举着这些“拯救虾”的标语在街边游行，这成了他的人生意义，而他才七岁。
So I do think that you might start with what matters to you, what matters most, what are some of those things, and on the basis of that, maybe think about how you could become. more purposeful. Are there certain things you might be able to engage in that are meaningful to the things that matter? Starting to live that way? Imagine, I can't wait to see that seven-year-old grandson grow up into an adult. Just boy, watch out, world. I'm wondering when the students that you are teaching in college, Vic, they often feel so much pressure on their shoulders. They're being asked to figure out, you know, their first jobs, their life trajectory, the areas that interest them. Does adding on the demand that they also do something that is purposeful add sort of one
所以我确实认为，你可以从对你来说最重要的事情开始，什么最重要，其中有哪些事情，在此基础上，也许可以思考你如何才能变得更有意义。有没有哪些特定事情，你可以参与其中，并对那些重要的事情具有意义？开始那样生活？想象一下，我迫不及待地想看到那个七岁的孙子长大成为一个成年人了。天哪，世界小心了。维克，我在想，当你在大学里教书时，你的学生们往往承受着巨大的压力。他们被要求弄清楚，你知道的，他们的第一份工作、他们的人生轨迹、他们感兴趣的领域。要求他们做一件有意义的事，会不会给他们的生活凭空添了一种压力？他们曾向你反映过这一点吗？我是这样看待这个问题的：我认为学生们需要了解自己是谁，这意味着他们的核心价值观是什么？
more stress to their lives? Do they ever report that to you? Here's how I think about that. I believe that students need to know who they are, meaning what are their core values? explore their identity is the identity that they're striving for does that fit almost like a suit try the suit on wear it for a while see whether that works for you do you like being this person who wants to be wealthy do you like being this person who wants to be generous do you like this person who wants to be a healer whatever try those things on for a change find out what your core values are what your identity is from those core values, and from that, find out whether the strengths that you are trying to develop are the right strengths. Because ultimately, I believe you will flourish
探索他们的身份：他们正在努力追求的身份，是否像一套西装那样合身？试穿一下这套西装，穿上一段时间，看看它是否适合你？你喜欢成为这样一个渴望财富的人吗？你喜欢成为这样一个慷慨的人吗？你喜欢成为这样一个想要成为治愈者的人吗？无论是什么，为了改变去试穿这些角色。找出你的核心价值观是什么，你的身份是什么。从这些核心价值观出发，去弄清楚你试图培养的优势是否是正确的优势。因为归根结底，我相信你会蓬勃发展，
if your behaviors, if your profession, if your emotions, all come from this root system, almost like a tree. So if you start with the roots, as opposed to starting with the branches of the tree, like what career do you want to be involved in? Well, the majority of people who are majoring in something 10 years later aren't doing that anymore. So start with what you value the most in your life. What are those important things? From that, a purpose can evolve. From that, you start looking at your strengths.
如果你的行为、你的职业、你的情感，全都源自这个根系，就像一棵树一样。所以如果你从根部开始，而不是从树枝开始——比如你想从事什么职业？好吧，10年后大多数主修某种专业的人已经不再做那个了。所以，从你生活中最珍视的东西开始。那些重要的事情是什么？由此，人生意义可以演化出来。从那里开始，你再去审视自己的优势。
And you may also find things that you need greater strength in. I might need to be more patient. I might need to be more inspiring. I might need to be more thoughtful, more studious, whatever those things are. How do I become those things? How do I build those strengths? And from that, then suddenly the profession starts becoming easier for you. And also, as we all know in our fields, opportunities come by.
你可能还会发现你需要更强大优势的领域。我可能需要更有耐心。我可能需要更有启发性。我可能需要更体贴、更好学，无论这些是什么。我如何才能成为那些人？我如何建立这些优势？从那以后，突然之间，职业对你来说就变得更容易了。而且，正如我们在各自领域所知的那样，机会也会降临。
And if you don't take that opportunity and you say, I can do that and you jump on that. And to some extent, even, you may have to fake it until you make it, as they like to say. having enough skill, having enough strength that undergirds that is really, really important. The final thing I'll say is if in the process you think about your core values and you're starting to question them, you might ask, if this is a tree metaphor, what is the reservoir underneath that root system that's feeding those roots, those values? Is it a religion? Is it a philosophy? Is it your community? Is it your parents? I think we need to have people, especially my students, what I have my students do, is try to explore the sources more.
如果你不抓住那个机会，而是说“我能做到”并扑上去。在某种程度上，甚至正如他们喜欢说的那样，你可能得“假装直到你成功”。拥有足够的技能，拥有能够支撑这一点的足够优势，真的是非常非常重要的。最后我要说的是，如果在过程中你思考了你的核心价值观并开始对它们产生质疑，你可能会问：如果这是一个树喻，那么那个根系下方滋养那些根和价值观的水库是什么？是一种宗教？是一种哲学？是你的社区？是你的父母？我认为我们需要让人们——尤其是我的学生，我让我的学生做的是——去更多地探索这些源泉。
Quite a few listeners wrote in with questions about how to prompt their loved ones to live more purposeful lives. One wrote in asking how to help her elderly parents continue to pursue purpose. Another listener asked if there was a way to encourage his adult siblings to lead more meaningful lives. What advice would you have for these people who want to know how to encourage others to live a life of purpose, Vic? So often people's parents will tell you, especially when they move into their 70s or 80s or even 90s, I've lost my purpose. I used to be a big shot at work or, you know, I had this family and now suddenly I don't. I don't really have that purpose anymore. How do we help those people? How do we help?
有不少听众发来问题，询问如何促使他们所爱的人过上更有意义的生活。一位听众发信询问如何帮助她年迈的父母继续追求人生意义。另一位听众询问是否有办法鼓励他的成年兄弟姐妹过上更有意义的生活。维克，对于这些想要知道如何鼓励他人过上有意义的生活的人，你有什么建议？通常人们的父母会告诉你，特别是当他们进入70多岁、80多岁甚至90多岁时：“我已经失去了我的人生意义。我过去在工作是个大人物，或者，你知道的，我曾有这个家庭，而现在突然间我没有了。我真的不再拥有那种人生意义了。”我们如何帮助这些人？我们如何帮助
older people in general find greater purpose. But one of the pieces of advice we give pretty regularly to older people is to think about volunteering. Volunteerism has been shown to improve people's purpose. It seems to actually improve our epigenetic or our biological clocks, actually. So volunteering can be really helpful. If you think about yourself and then your family and then your friends as being in concentric circles. And moving out further and further in these concentric circles of helping others, being
老年人总体上找到更深的人生意义？但我们定期给老年人的建议之一，就是考虑做志愿服务。志愿服务已被证明能够改善人们的人生意义。它似乎实际上能改善我们的表观遗传钟或生物钟。所以志愿服务真的很有帮助。如果你把你自己、然后你的家人、然后你的朋友看作是同心圆。并在这些帮助他人的同心圆中越走越远，对
kind to these other people. As you move further out, I think actually you become a happier person. Now, that's just the theory that I have, but I really do believe that. I tell people who are my students in public health, you will end up helping people. It will be your job to help people. Many people who you might not ever meet, you might not know, and to some extent you might not even like. That becomes your job. And if you take that job really seriously, you are in public health. And you will, as Jonas Salk said, be a good ancestor. You will leave a legacy. on purpose, how living for what matters most changes everything. Vic, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
这些人保持善良。随着你走向更远，我认为你实际上会成为一个更快乐的人。现在，这只是我的理论，但我确实对此深信不疑。我告诉那些在公共卫生专业的学生，你们最终会去帮助别人。帮助别人将是你们的工作。许多人可能是你永远不会见到的，你可能不认识，甚至在某种程度上你可能根本不喜欢。那将成为你的工作。如果你非常认真地对待这份工作，你就是在从事公共卫生事业。而且，正如乔纳斯·索尔克所说，你将成为一个优秀的祖先。你将留下遗产。
It was my pleasure and honor, Shankar. Thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Christian Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Audum Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Wood. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. We wanted to take a moment to say thank you to Loom by Atlassian
关于人生意义：为最重要的事情而活如何改变一切。维克，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的脑》。这是我的荣幸，尚卡尔。谢谢。《隐藏的脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·帕尔、克里斯蒂安·王、劳拉·克雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥杜姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的脑》的执行编辑。我们想花一点时间感谢 Atlassian 旗下的 Loom
for sponsoring the Hidden Brain 2025 Perceptions tour. While on tour, we asked members of the audience to tell us about some of the best advice they ever received. Here's one piece of wisdom shared during our stop in Boston. My name is Candace, and this is my name is. And this is really simple advice, it's not long, but it's something that I think about a lot that someone told me once, and I think it was when I was in college, and I would get very overwhelmed about things, tests, you know, all the things that had to be done. And they said, are you going to remember this 50 years from now? Like, is this really going to be important 50 years from now? And it has really helped me a lot, even with little problems or arguments you have with somebody. or the way you want to go somewhere, you want to do it this way,
赞助《隐藏的脑》2025年“感知”巡回演出。在巡演期间，我们请观众们分享了他们收到的最好的一些建议。以下是我们停留在波士顿期间分享的一条智慧。我叫坎迪斯，这是我的名字是。这是一个非常简单的建议，并不长，但它是我经常想起的一件事。有人曾经告诉我，我想那是在我上大学的时候，当时我对事情感到非常不知所措，比如考试，你知道的，所有必须要做的事情。他们说：“从现在起50年后你还会记得这件事吗？这在50年后真的很重要吗？”这真的帮了我很多忙，甚至对于小问题或者你和某人的争吵，
to think, is this thing that I'm stressing over going to matter 50 years from now? Yeah, that's a wonderful advice. Yep. Thank you. Thank you. Thanks to Candace for sharing that advice, and thanks again to Loom for sponsoring the 2025 Perceptions Tour.
或者你想去某个地方的方式，你想以这种方式去做，去思考：我正在为之感到压力的这件事，在50年后还会有关系吗？是的，这是一个极好的建议。是的。谢谢。谢谢。感谢坎迪斯分享这个建议，也再次感谢 Loom 赞助2025年“感知”巡回演出。
Loom is AI-powered video communication that moves teams forward, whether you're sharing feedback, obtaining approvals, or setting content. It removes the friction by making it easy to share and collaborate on work without having to be in the same room or time zone. Try loom today at loom.com. That's L-O-O-O-M.com. I'm Shankar Vedantham. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Loom 是一款由人工智能驱动的视频沟通工具，它能推动团队向前发展，无论你是在分享反馈、获取审批还是设定内容。它通过让你轻松共享工作并进行协作，而无需身处同一房间或时区，从而消除了摩擦。今天就在 loom.com 上试用 loom 吧。网址是 L-O-O-O-M.com。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们回头见。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。